Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Mon
Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka
Für kurzen Moment überlegt, ob es nicht 200 heißt, aber ich glaube, es heißt immer wenigstens 300.
Dan, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Boah, ich bin übelst im Arsch, Leute. Ich weiß auch nicht, es muss mir irgendwie...
Also neue Arbeit ist irgendwie anstrengender als die alte.
Macht zwar mehr Bock, aber ist anstrengender.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich mich noch nicht komplett eingewöhnt habe.
Weißt du, was eine AS400 ist? Ja, weiß ich.
Das ist ein fettes IBM-Storage-System.
Oder ein IBM-Host, aber ich glaube ein IBM-Storage-System.
Kommt das auf YouTube?
Vielleicht, mal gucken. Wenn wir was richtig ausgefallenes finden, dann vielleicht.
Bereust du es nicht, studiert zu haben? Nee, gar nicht, das Gegenteil.
Ich hatte nie Bock darauf zu studieren und jetzt bin ich froh, dass es nicht notwendig war.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, auf gar keinen Fall, Alter. Im Leben studiere ich nicht mehr.
Im Leben nicht. Nee, bloß auf gar keinen Fall.
Nee, wie gesagt, niemals. Den Stress gebe ich mir jetzt mit fast 40 sicherlich nicht mehr.
Mal ganz einfach abgesehen, in der Zeit würde ich ja nicht mal gescheit Geld verdienen.
Warum soll ich das machen? Nee.
Gelnhausen-Dude.
Ich weiß, du wohnst bei mir um die Ecke, ja? Wenn du aus Gelnhausen kommst.
Nee, auf gar keinen Fall.
Ist es echt so schlimm? Erzähl doch nichts.
Sound ist doch alles okay, oder?
Sound ist doch alles okay, oder? Passt doch.
Außer, ich renne wieder gegen irgendwem.
Irgendwem hier laufend gegen das... irgendwie mit der Backe oder so.
Irgendwie klappt das hoch und dann hier renne ich die ganze Zeit so gegen das Mikrofon.
Das hört sich natürlich kacke an.
Hab ich... hab ich eins von der Arbeit gespons... also in Antwort gesponsort bekommen.
Chunker.
Hatte ich eigentlich recht, was ich gesagt habe?
Ich glaube, das ist ein fettes IBM-Storage-System. Ist das richtig? Ja.
AS400. IBM.
Oder war das... oder war das ein Host?
IBM...
Ähm...
Nee.
Das ist ein IBM... das war ein IBM-Host. Okay.
Dann habe ich es verwechselt.
Dann... dann habe ich... dann habe ich es verwechselt.
Aber irgendwas in der Richtung.
Nee, dann war es... dann war es irgend so ein IBM-Mainframe wahrscheinlich.
Irgend so Zeug, was... ja, ja, i... System...
Ja.
Frankfurt-Beste.
Außer die ganzen Assis.
Nee, ich glaube, das war... nee, nee, nee, also...
Das war damals auch schon ziemlich... ziemlich Oldschool-Zeug.
Ich meine, ich habe 2007 in dem Dreh angefangen. Da war das schon...
... lange da.
Nee, nee, also ja, vielleicht würden mich manche Themen aus dem Studium interessieren, aber...
... ich würde im Leben kein Studium mehr machen.
Nehme am Mittwoch am Google-Get-Certified-Programm teil.
Cloud-Architekt-Zertifizierung. Bin mal gespannt, wie Google das handhabt.
Ja, was ist denn das für eine... für eine Zertifizierung?
Ist das jetzt eher sowas... Oh, Moment, ich muss mal kurz die Musik changen, ja.
Es läuft ja die ganze Zeit immer der gleiche...
Ähm, das muss ja nicht sein. Was machen wir denn hier? Komm, bisschen...
Bisschen Wupp, Wupp, Wupp im Hintergrund. Da gibt es ja eigentlich... da kann man nichts verkehrt machen.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ist das eher sowas, so wie der Internet-Führerschein?
Oder ist das was, wo Google Webcam-Überwachung haben will und...
... zeige mal deine Wand, dein Hintergrund, dein Monitor, was unterm Schreibtisch hängt, niemand darf in den Raum reinkommen und sowas.
Also ich hab von...
Machen wir den Valomat?
Ach, ist es mal wieder soweit? No, heute nicht. Da kann ich mich... da kann ich mich drauf...
... nicht drauf konzentrieren.
Aber wir sollten das mal wieder die nächsten Tage machen.
Es wird doch... es wird doch tatsächlich bald gewählt, habe ich im Hinterkopf, ne? Ich hab schon...
Ich hab schon einen Brief bekommen. Ich glaube, das ist...
... nächsten Monat? Ende nächsten Monat, oder?
Oder Mitte nächsten Monat, irgendwie? Ja, 8. Oktober, ok.
Ja, dauert noch ungefähr einen Monat, aber trotzdem. Ja, das machen wir.
Machen wir. Aber nicht heute, da hab ich echt keinen Nerv drauf.
Ja, also was ich bei Microsoft schon rausgehört habe, ist von einem unserer...
... Schulungstypen, die früher...
... bei uns die Azure-Schulung gemacht haben.
Die haben gesagt, Microsoft ist bei den Zertifizierungen extrem pingelig.
So, also du wirst beobachtet, die gesamte Zertifizierung über.
Du musst deine Hände filmen, du musst den Raum filmen, den Hintergrund filmen.
Du musst... auf Rückfrage musst du... also zweiten... musst Raum zeigen, kein zweiter Monitor.
Die Tür darf nicht aufgemacht werden, die Tür darf nicht aufgehen, während du deine Prüfung machst oder deine Zertifizierung machst.
Und was ich jetzt gehört habe, ist, manche Leute schließen sich... jetzt ohne Spaß, ja?
Manche Leute schließen sich im Klo ein, um irgendeine aktuelle Microsoft-Zertifizierung zu machen.
Weil im Klo ist nichts, wo man abgucken kann. Die sitzen dann auf dem Klo mit ihrem Laptop, filmen sich...
... und streamen das an Microsoft, machen darauf die Zertifizierung, Tür abgeschlossen, kann nichts passieren.
Darf man spülen? Ich gehe davon aus, sobald du die Hand wegnimmst vom Notebook, wird der Typ sich gleich beschweren.
Was ist denn der Online...
... TU...
... EFL...
... Test?
Du meinst jetzt hier im Stream oder auf YouTube? Weil auf YouTube habe ich ein anderes Mikrofon.
Dürfte heute durchs Erzett mit einem Playcenter. Ah, nice.
Habt ihr noch welche? Das ist ja bisher ein bisschen außer Mode gekommen, die letzten Jahre über.
Und gab's... oder habe ich irgendeinen Post gelesen auf Reddit?
Irgendwie, alle Städte Deutschlands oder irgendwie...
Ich weiß nicht, wie der Titel war, irgendwie...
Alle Städte Deutschlands kommen zu einer Hausparty.
Wer bringt was mit? Und dann hat irgendwie einer sinngemäß sowas geschrieben.
Frankfurt bringt die Assis mit, die man nicht in seiner Wohnung haben will.
Entschuldigung, ja.
Genau das trifft's ganz gut.
Letztens wieder am Hauptbahnhof gewesen, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, Leute.
Frankfurt.
Letztens morgen... also letztens, letztens ist gut.
Weiß ich nicht, Dienstag oder Mittwoch war das?
Dienstag, Dienstag war ich in Frankfurt.
Dienstag komme ich, laufe ich vom Gleis runter durch den Hauptbahnhof durch, also relativ früh morgens.
Aber so da schon ordentlich was los ist.
Und dann liegt irgendein Typ... kennt ihr am Frankfurter Bahnhof? Das muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Maps, Frankfurt, Hauptbahnhof.
Ihr kennt doch diese Stände.
Die, ähm...
Moment, haben wir irgendwelche Bilder, Frankfurt?
Da gibt's doch so...
Nicht Maps, warum suche ich Maps, Alter? Ich will Frankfurt, Hauptbahnhof innen.
Da gibt's doch so Stände zwischen den Gleisen, wo Zeug verkauft wird.
Sowas, ja, ja, ja!
Da ist es doch.
Man erkennt's, man erkennt... na.
Ey, das sieht anders aus.
Doch, hier, man sieht's, genau hier, diese Stände meine ich, ne?
Und da liegt ein Typ genau hier drunter.
Der... der liegt da, ich weiß nicht, was mit dem ist, der lag da einfach drinnen, so.
So schräg unter dem Tisch, so.
So über dem... über dem Tischzeug drüber, so, so als hat's...
So als wäre er komplett elastisch, lag der hier einfach so... so quer durch den Tisch durch.
Das ist selten im Hauptbahnhof mittlerweile geworden.
Weil die alle möglichen Leute verjagen, also der konnte da noch nicht so lange liegen.
Er lag einfach hier so durch... durch den Tisch durchgewickelt unten.
Joa, was... was ist denn da los?
Aber Frankfurt ist eh so ein Ding, ey, das ist so eine Kackstadt, Alter, ich...
Früher fand ich's geil, der Gedanke, regelmäßig nach Frankfurt zu fahren.
Früher, als ich mit meinem Vater öfters nach Frankfurt gefahren bin, da fand ich Frankfurt super.
Aber seitdem ich da regelmäßig so hin muss, und ich muss ja glücklicherweise nicht mehr so oft nach Frankfurt reinfahren,
mir ist es eh komplett unverständlich, wie ich's früher geschafft habe.
Moment, ich... ich muss das... ich muss das...
Ich muss das in zwei... diese Antwort muss ich jetzt in zwei Teile gliedern.
Also, ich verstehe nicht, wie ich es früher geschafft habe, dort jeden Tag hinzufahren,
und wie ich es früher geschafft habe, dort jeden Tag hinzufahren, bei einer Fünf-Tage-Woche.
Es ist mir komplett unverständlich, wie das möglich ist.
Und, wie ich's... es geht ja noch schlimmer, es geht ja noch schlimmer.
Wie ich's früher geschafft habe, jeden Tag bei einer Fünf-Tage-Woche nach Frankfurt zu fahren,
und morgens mit dem Bus teilweise noch zum Bahnhof zu fahren, um von dort mit der Bahn nach Frankfurt zu fahren.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich das überhaupt geschafft habe.
Mit dem Bus... Leute, ist schon jemand mal die Ehre gehabt, in Hanau mit dem Bus zu fahren?
Also, der... das Fahren ist nicht so das Problem in Hanau mit dem Bus.
Das Problem ist eher, dass der Bus halt einfach nicht auftaucht.
Und, damals waren die auch so rückständig noch, da hattest du keine Anzeigen irgendwie, wo man sehen konnte,
ah, der kommt heute halt acht Minuten später.
So, mittlerweile haben die ja an einigen Haltestellen solche... solche Tafeln oben,
wo du halbwegs siehst, wo die Busse sind und so, das gab's damals nicht.
Und... und ich erzähl' euch jetzt mal die Ultra... ich erzähl' euch jetzt mal die Ultra-Boomer-Story,
was mich früher extrem abgefuckt hat.
Das ist so ne... auch so Hanau-Nahverkehrs-Geschichte.
Ich war mal in Hamburg vor zig Jahren, mit dem Zug, so.
Das war noch zu Zeiten, wo ich, äh, 24-7-MMO-Kreiselcrind gemacht hab'.
Ich hab' jemand besucht in Hamburg.
Dann bin ich zurückgefahren, bin relativ spät angekommen... in Hanau.
Und... dann bin ich ausgestiegen am Hauptbahnhof rübergelaufen und wollte gucken,
wann kommt denn der nächste Bus?
Und dann, wie immer, war damals der Plan vom Bus rausgerissen.
Und das hat mich schon so krass früher immer aufgeregt.
Die ganzen Kackspasten, die immer die Fahrpläne von den Bussen rausgerissen haben.
Und man muss sich das mal vorstellen, in Hanau gab es jahrelang an den Bushaltestellen am Hauptbahnhof,
davor und dahinter, äh, keine... keine Fahrpläne.
Weil das immer irgendwelche Leute rausgerissen haben
und die haben's nicht geschafft, innerhalb von einem halben Jahr den Scheiß zu replacen.
Am Hauptbahnhof, man!
Ja.
Und das waren auch Zeiten, bevor man einfach auf's Handy geguckt hat.
Also du hattest schon ein Handy, aber du hattest auch kein Smartphone, du hattest ein richtiges Handy.
Mega für'n Arsch.
Ich bin halt heimgelaufen von da, aber trotzdem.
Nachts irgendwann um eins oder so halt ziemlich kacke.
Fährt halt aus Prinzip auch kein Bus mehr, ne? Kam nix.
Richtig für'n Arsch.
Also Nahverkehr, es war schon immer, war schon immer so.
Also ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, wie ich das geschafft hab.
Fünf Tage die Woche, jeden Tag nach Frankfurt, mit der Bahn und zum Bahnhof mit dem Zug.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das nervlich überhaupt durchgestanden hab.
Es ist mir... also ich sag das jetzt nicht, um das irgendwie zu übertreiben.
Ich kann das wirklich nicht nachvollziehen, wie das möglich gewesen ist.
Weiß nicht.
Ich muss sagen, Frankfurt ist so'n Ding, also...
Auf der einen Seite find ich Frankfurt mega nice, auf der anderen Seite find ich's abgrundtief scheiße.
Das heißt, dass beides so kombiniert geht so, ja?
Es ist...
Ich weiß nicht, Frankfurt ist echt so'n Ding...
Wenn man da mal hingeht zum ersten Mal und läuft durch das Bankenviertel, guckt sich die Hochhäuser an,
geht vielleicht mal irgendwie auf den Main-Tower aktuell drauf, geht irgendwie hin, guckt sich das oben an
und hat so dieses Weltstadt-Feeling, so Großstadt-Weltstadt-Feeling, das erstmal überall...
Ich mein, ich glaube, es gibt in Deutschland keinen Platz, wo Arm und Reich so eng zusammen sind wie in Frankfurt.
Also in Frankfurt, Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel, da kann's dir passieren, dass du den Typ hast, der Crack-Rauchen in der Ecke sitzt und heute irgendwie nachmittags verreckt
und an ihm vorbei mit zwei Meter Abstand läuft irgendwie einer mit 50 Millionen auf dem Konto.
Also das hast du, glaube ich, echt nur in Frankfurt so krass, auch in der Gehäuftheit, ja?
Also, aber auf der einen Seite ist Frankfurt mega-nice, wenn du dir überlegst, theoretisch kannst du im Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel, wenn man das jetzt mal übertrieben sagt,
du kannst im Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel auf, nein, nicht ganz, aber fast, auf die Welt kommen, nicht ganz, weil ich glaube, direkt im Bahnhofsviertel ist gar kein Krankenhaus,
du kannst, oder gut, auf die Welt kommen kannst du theoretisch auch ohne Grenzen, du kannst auf die Welt kommen, du kannst in die Schule gehen, du kannst deine Ausbildung machen, du kannst studieren gehen, Stückchen weiter,
du kannst dein komplettes Leben von Geburt bis Abkratzen eigentlich komplett nur im Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel verbringen und du kannst dort alles machen, was du willst, was es gibt.
Das funktioniert, aber ob er das machen wird, ist natürlich wieder was anderes.
Also es ist schon, es hat schon nice Seiten in Frankfurt, aber mittlerweile überwiegen für mich die negativen Seiten, Leute, wenn du am Hauptbahnhof vorbeigehst, es gibt ja regelmäßig, was richtiges Meme mittlerweile schon geworden ist auf Reddit,
Reddit Frankfurt, Reddit Frankfurt besteht ja zur Hälfte aus Posts, ist es sicher am Hauptbahnhof, ja?
Also wenn ihr das durchscrollt, da kommt gefühlt dreimal am Tag der Post, ist es sicher am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Ich bin mir mittlerweile nicht sicher, ob das Gemime ist oder ob die Leute das wirklich meinen, also ja, ich kann euch sagen, Leute, es ist sicher am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof, du musst dir keine Gedanken machen am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof, dass du gleich abgestochen wirst oder so.
Es ist jetzt kein irgendwie, was gibt es, Leute, mit was, wo ist es denn echt gefährlich so, an welchem Bahnhof?
Oder sagen wir mal so, Frankfurt ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, irgendwie Brasilien Großstadt in irgendeinem Ghetto oder so.
Also Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof, musst du keine Gedanken, keine Gedanken machen, dass du gleich abgestochen wirst.
Nichtsdestotrotz, natürlich, was da so rumhängt an Leuten, also du musst schon ein bisschen aufpassen, dass dich nicht einer anhustet, irgendwie Pisse reintrittst, einer vor dich fällt oder seine Windel verliert oder so, da ist ja alles.
Also Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof ist wirklich alles am Start.
Ich hatte schon Leute, die hatten eine Windel an und sind da halbnackig rumgelaufen am Hauptbahnhof.
Am geilsten war der Typ, den habe ich ein paar mal gesehen vor ein paar Jahren, schon lange nicht mehr, wahrscheinlich lebt er nicht mehr.
Da ist so ein Typ immer durchs Bahnhofsviertel gerannt, der ist immer, muss man sich mal vorstellen, also ich habe den immer gesehen, wenn ich, Google Maps, ich habe den Kerl immer gesehen, wenn ich Mittagessen gegangen bin damals.
Ach Quatsch, wir sind in Hanau, das sieht nicht aus wie Frankfurt.
Hier, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, also guck mal, Kaiserstraße, Kaiserstraße.
So, wenn man hier hinten essen gegangen ist, hier gab es früher jede Menge Burgerläden und sowas, die haben Corona irgendwie nicht so richtig überlebt.
Zumindest ist die Kaiserstraße mittags immer einer langgerannt, der Flugzeug gespielt hat.
Und ich meine, das ist kein Kind oder so, was weiß ich, das war etwa 25, 30 oder so.
Gut, die sehen ja manchmal, die ganzen Drogenabhängigen in Frankfurt sehen ja oftmals ein bisschen älter aus, als sie sind.
Da ist die Kaiserstraße und hier so Moselstraße, Kaiserstraße, ist der langgelaufen und hat Flugzeug gemacht.
Der ist da mit ausgebreiteten Armen, den habe ich paar mal gesehen beim Mittagessen.
Der ist da mit ausgebreiteten Armen über die Straße gerannt und hat dabei gemacht, brrr, brrr.
Und hat dann mit den Armen gesteuert.
Und ist dann auch so, wisst ihr, wie Kinder Flugzeug spielen, der ist da rumgerannt über die Straße.
da Flugzeug spielen hals, ist da rumgerannt über die Straße.
brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrRRwww
Und ist da halt rumgesegelt über die Kaiserstraße mit das.
Ja so Leute hast du da in Frankfurt.
Ja das ist schon echt, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Das ist schon echt verrückte Leute.
Und dann hatten wir auch mal hier hinten,
ich vermute,
irgendwo hier Taunusstraße an der Ecke muss das
Grillhaus,
Ja, irgendwie da an der Ecke.
Da hier, wo auch Frankfurt Rotlichtmilieu ist.
Da hab ich mal einen Überfall gesehen, mitten auf der Straße.
Und zwar...
Das hab ich euch, glaub ich, schon mal erzählt.
Da sind wir vom Mittagessen zurückgelaufen.
Und laufen halt zwei Mädels.
Und auf einmal kommt von hinten einer gerannt.
Haut der einen auf den Kopf.
Schnappt die Tasche und rennt weg.
So denkt man sich halt so, okay, Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel.
Ja, nicht weiter wild.
Aber das Witzige daran, oder das Schlimme daran, könnte man sagen.
Die kannten sich.
Auf einmal schreit die dem hinterher so nach dem Motto.
Karl, was machst du denn?
Musst dir mal vorstellen.
Der war so neben der Spur.
Der hat irgendjemand ausgeraubt, den er kannte.
Und die wussten auch, wer das ist.
Das ist halt...
Das ist halt schon hardcore.
Das war bestimmt Familie, ja.
Bekannte aus Offenbach wahrscheinlich.
Ja, also die Ecke hier hinten ist wirklich eklig.
Einmal muss keine gehen.
Im Hauptbahnhof, ganz ehrlich.
Im Hauptbahnhof selber.
Ist wirklich sicher.
Da läuft so viel Bahn-Security und allgemein rum.
Da hast du auch kaum irgendwie merkwürdige Leute.
Wo halt wirklich ganz viel Asis rumhängen.
Ist irgendwie hier so an der Seite.
Ich weiß nicht, warum überhaupt hier immer an der Seite.
Hier vorne war auch früher der McDonalds.
Also hier diese Ecke zum rumlaufen.
Hier hatte ich auch mal den, der mit einer Windel rumgelaufen ist.
Der ist halt nackig mit einer Windel rumgelaufen.
Keine Ahnung, was da abging.
So, und dann ist halt auch richtig eklig hier so.
Niddastraße, Moselstraße.
Dann hier hoch, Taunusstraße.
Das ist so die richtig krasse Asi-Ecke.
Das ist auch, wo der Typ mir irgendwie letztens, was ich euch erzählt hab.
Marjona, Marjona antreten wollte.
Ja gut, aber wie gesagt.
Frankfurt ist auf der einen Seite mega nice.
Auf der anderen Seite mega kacke.
Also irgendwie kommt so auf, geht so halbwegs raus.
Ja, das ist fast normal.
Der Hauptbahnhof hat ja mehrere U-Bahn-Ausgänge.
Zum Beispiel geht es hier über die Straße.
Und dann direkt hier gegenüber raus.
Es gibt aber auch so einen kleinen Ausgang.
Irgendwie noch da einen kleinen.
Und irgendwie noch hier auf der Münchner Straße irgendwie noch einen kleinen Ausgang.
Und man sieht das, man sieht das glaube ich irgendwie sogar ganz.
Sollte nicht hier vorne eigentlich.
Hä?
Sieht man das von hier oben nicht?
Hier, hier ist ein Ausgang.
Hier genau.
Traffic Snack Sandwich.
Ne, das ist doch der Eingang zum Hauptbahnhof.
Man erkennt das nicht richtig.
Und diese Dinger Leute.
Also wenn ihr diese Treppen runter geht.
Hier drüben ist eigentlich auch eine gewesen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das scheinen aber aktuelle Bilder.
Vielleicht sieht man es einfach nicht richtig.
Hier drüben ist normalerweise auch eine.
Zumindest bei diesen kleinen Treppen müsste tatsächlich ein bisschen.
Ich glaube hier sieht man es auch ein bisschen.
Stimmt hier gibt es ja mittlerweile Street View.
Ja hier.
Hier ist der.
Da geht es runter zum Hauptbahnhof.
Und da geht es runter zum Hauptbahnhof.
Und da müsst ihr tatsächlich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Weil hier gammeln tatsächlich die Leute die sich Zeug spritzen und sowas auch rum.
Und da liegen auch Spritzen.
Also vor den Leuten selbst muss man gar nicht so viel Schiss haben.
Die sind so mit sich selbst beschäftigt.
Aber hier liegen halt auch oftmals die Spritzen.
Oder die Treppe ist vollgepisst.
Also hier ist eine Rolltreppe.
Und hier ist glaube ich eine normale Treppe.
Und das ist halt auch teilweise übelst vollgepisst.
Und stinkt wie Sau.
Aber da müsst ihr tatsächlich ein bisschen auf Spritzen gucken.
Und den ersten richtig so Kulturschock.
Wo ich angefangen habe in Frankfurt zu arbeiten.
Hatte ich mal hier.
Kann man nicht hier lang?
Street View.
Wie macht man Street View wieder aus?
Leute ich bin so dumm Google zu bedienen.
Wie macht man das?
So?
Okay.
Wo ich richtigen Kulturschock hatte.
Als ich angefangen habe in Frankfurt zu arbeiten.
Ja aber hier sind wir doch genau richtig.
Hier sind wir doch genau richtig.
Also erstmal Moselleck.
Wenn du da reinguckst weißt du schon was Sache ist.
Aber wo ich richtig schocke ist hier so ein Waschsalon.
Genau hier ist so ein Waschsalon.
Bilde mir einen das denn?
Das muss hier gewesen sein.
So.
Und ich weiß nicht was es mit Waschsalons ist.
Aber irgendwie gammeln da auch den ganzen Tag.
Irgendwelche merkwürdigen Leute rum.
Und in einem meiner ersten Mittagspausen.
Bin ich hier runter.
Bin ich hier lang gelaufen.
Ich glaube ich wollte mir hier irgendwie.
Frikadellenbrötchen oder sowas holen.
Nee Street View ist mittlerweile neu.
Street View fährt seit ein paar Monaten.
Wieder in Deutschland rum.
Zumindest ich laufe hier vorbei.
Ich bin neu in Frankfurt.
Ich bin das nicht so gewöhnt.
Ich laufe hier vorbei.
Steht hier so ein komischer Typ in der Tür.
An die Tür.
Also an die.
Also an die Wand gelehnt.
Steht da dran.
Grinst mich an.
Und ich gucke ihn halt an.
Und denke mir nichts böses dabei.
Und auf einmal holt er so eine Spritze raus.
Und sticht die sich in den Arm.
Und drückt die rein.
Komplett random.
Du läufst an einem vorbei.
Der lacht dich an.
Holt eine Spritze raus.
Drückt sich in den Arm.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Wo bist du hier gelandet?
So und dann war ich.
Dann war ich hier drin.
Hab mir.
Ich hab mir kein Frikadellenbrötchen.
Schnitzelbrötchen habe ich mir glaube ich geholt.
Schnitzelbrötchen geholt.
Und ist komplett.
Komplett in seiner Welt.
Und hängt da rum.
Da habe ich mir gesagt.
Wo bist du hier gelandet?
Mittlerweile kriegt man das gar nicht mehr so richtig mit.
Frankfurt ist schon abartig.
Hier in der Ecke bin ich halt viel früher.
Noch in der Mittagspause.
Generell unterwegs gewesen.
Und du hast auch hier gerade.
Wenn du in die Moselstraße reingehst.
So neben so Abstellen.
Früher standen da gar nicht so viele Roller rum.
Aber du hast hier oftmals Baustellen.
Hier irgendwo ist auch Scientology glaube ich.
Können auch eine Straße weiter.
Ich glaube noch eine Straße weiter ist Scientology.
Zumindest hier so zwischen.
Zwischen diesen Dingern.
Da habe ich mal einen gesehen.
Der hat sich einfach zwischen so zwei.
Zwischen so zwei Autos und so einer.
Und so einer Baustelle.
Hat er sich einfach hingesetzt.
Mitten am Tacher die Hose runter gelassen.
Ist halt Frankfurt.
Ich weiß.
Für manch einen noch super harmlos.
Für manch einen kompletter Kulturschock.
Man gewöhnt sich mit der Zeit dran.
Scientology. Nein.
Frankfurt hat auch Scientology.
Guck.
Ach da. Okay sind sogar noch zwei Straßen weiter.
Guck Scientology ist hier.
Sieht man von außen gar nicht so.
Die sind ziemlich verbarrikadiert.
Die sind so silber außen.
Wo ist Scientology?
Ich sehe sie gar nicht jetzt.
Hier.
Sie sind so silber außen.
Hier ist Scientology.
Guck mal die sind komplett verbarrikadiert.
So mit.
Mit Stahltür und allem.
Neugierig.
Scientology Kirche Frankfurt TV.
Weiß nicht ob das jemals schon jemand
Freiwillig sich angeguckt hat.
Kommen sie hier rein.
Finden sie selbst heraus.
Die haben ja auch so einen tollen Ruf.
Da will man sicherlich rein.
Die sehen auch so aus als gehst du da einmal rein
und kommst nie wieder raus.
Das sieht halt echt nicht einladend aus.
Das sind Koreaner.
Da war ich ab und zu schon mal.
Das war ganz okay.
Naja.
Aber ich finde es sehr nice.
Ist das die Bahn?
Ich bin mir gerade unsicher ob ich in der richtigen Straße bin.
Das müsste die Bahn sein hier.
Ich glaube das ist die Bahn.
Ja.
Das ist die Bahn.
Und das Ding hier ist auch heftig.
Also man denkt sich ja hier so
Hey das ist so ein
Was auch immer das ist.
Zumindest hier pissen den ganzen Tag Leute dabei.
Wenn ihr hier vorbeiläuft lauft immer
da rum und nicht hier rum.
Weil die Ecke hier ist immer voll gepisst.
Also falls mal einer wissen will
wo die Bahn in Frankfurt ist.
Hier ist die Bahn in Frankfurt.
Gut.
Genug Frankfurter Ghetto inspiziert.
Das stimmt.
Hanau Hauptbahnhof ist ordentlich umgebaut.
Aber die sind immer noch heftig am umbauen.
Moin Max.
Was sagst du?
Lieber kleine Firma Ausbildung machen?
Oder große Firma?
Weil manche sagen bei großen Firmen hat man
danach Vorteile bei der Jobsuche nach der Ausbildung.
Ganz ehrlich.
Was näher ist und dir besser gefällt.
Also wo du die einfachere Anfahrt hast
musst du dir immer vorstellen
wie abfuck ist eine Stunde plus
am Tag hin und zurück und so.
Das ist halt voll für den Arsch.
Die die dir besser gefällt
und die näher ist.
Natürlich kannst du jetzt noch sagen
die die mehr Geld bezahlen
die vielleicht die besseren
Technologien hat und was auch immer.
Aber ich würde es
komplett nach persönlicher
Präferenz aussuchen
wo ich meine Ausbildung mache.
Bei großen Firmen ist halt meistens etwas anonymer
und es fällt nicht so sehr auf wenn du mal irgendwie
bisschen
weniger Bock hast
für eine Woche oder so.
Bei kleinen Unternehmen kriegt man
ich meine das muss bei großen Firmen nicht so sein.
Es kann auch sein dass sie im Team ganz genau auf die Azubis gucken.
Große Firma ist halt
meistens anonymer.
Aber ganz ehrlich für die Ausbildung
bei großen Firmen
hast du eventuell mehr Glück
dass die Plan haben was sie machen.
Das ist schon so.
Bei kleinen Firmen ist eher so ein bisschen hit or miss.
So nach dem Motto manche geben sich halt
richtig Mühe weil sie halt selbst die Leute
haben wollen danach und halt die gut ausbilden
wollen. Bei manchen hast du gar keinen Bock.
Sowas ist sicherlich konsistenter
in großen Unternehmen. Aber ich würde die nehmen
die näher ist und die dir persönlich mehr zusagt.
Ich meine hast du denn überhaupt
zwei zur Auswahl? Steht das überhaupt
zur
Debatte ob groß oder klein?
Da war ich nicht. Nein da war ich
noch nie. Das ist richtig. Da will ich auch nie hin.
Also ich war in Berlin am Hauptbahnhof.
Das hat mir schon gereicht.
Das erste was ich. Ohne Scheiß Leute.
Wirklich. Jetzt
ungelogen. Das erste was mir passiert ist.
Berliner Hauptbahnhof. Also erstens.
Das allererste was mir passiert ist ich war am falschen
Ausgang weil ich bei dem Ding nicht durchblicke.
Aber das erste was mir passiert ist
ich bin am richtigen Ausgang raus
und legit
das erste was ich gesehen hab nachdem ich
die Tür geöffnet hab war irgendein Penner
also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
der mir ins Gesicht gehustet hat.
Da dachte ich mir so ist wie daheim.
Wobei
die Penner Anzahl in Frankfurt
doch höher ist.
In Hauptbahnhof
und Umgebung wie in Berlin.
Aber das war wirklich das erste. Ich hab die Tür aufgemacht
und das erste was ich mitkriege ist
einer der quasi direkt vor mir auftaucht
mich anhustet.
Und der halt auch so ausschaut als ob wer weiß was der für
Krankheit hat.
Das ist meine erste Erfahrung
gewesen in Berlin.
Also ich habe echt keinerlei Interesse
noch in andere
also in schlimmere Berliner
Stadtteile irgendwie zu
gehen oder zu kommen.
Gar kein Bock.
Ist hier schon mal was geklaut worden?
Nein. Tatsächlich. Mir ist noch nie was
wüsste ich wahrscheinlich.
Also nicht das ich es mitbekommen hätte.
Mir ist tatsächlich noch nie
was geklaut worden.
Und ich bin auch in Frankfurt noch nie
überfallen worden.
Also ich weiß von zwei Leuten
mein ehemaliger Chef
wurde mal überfallen.
Das weiß ich aus dem Grund
weil er mich damals, da war ich noch Azubi
dann hat er mich
zur Polizei geschickt
sein Port Money abholen paar Tage später.
Er hat gesagt Max geh doch mal dahin
Polizeirevier 4 ist das glaube ich
wo ich hin musste.
Und
musste den
das ist das Port Money von meinem Chef
abholen. Der wurde überfallen
irgendwo Richtung Hauptbahnhof.
Oder wo auch immer
er war. Ich interpretiere
das einfach mal rein Richtung Hauptbahnhof.
Der wurde überfallen
und auch ein bisschen
abgedrehte Story die ich mal gehört habe.
Kollege auf der alten Arbeit
der Nachtschicht
der auch spät Nacht und so
Wochenendschicht machen muss.
Der muss wohl mal durch die Unterführung
zum Hauptbahnhof gelaufen sein mit dem Handy am Ohr.
Also hat er mir erzählt.
Dem glaube ich das.
Der kommt aus Hamburg und kennt
die richtigen Schlimmwecken.
Hat gemeint er ist mal mit dem Handy gelaufen
durch die Unterführung im Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Hat am Handy telefoniert
und dann irgendjemand
labert ihn von der Seite an.
Und er meint halt nur
jetzt nicht
und winkt ab und läuft halt weiter
mit dem Handy und meint er irgendwie
so ein paar Schritte als er weg war
hat er realisiert
dass der andere ein Messer hatte und meinte
das ist ein Überfall.
Hab ich mir auch gedacht. MonkaS alter.
Muss ich mir vorstellen.
Er hat es
erst gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Er hat quasi
den Überfäller
gebetet.
Den Räuber gebetet. Keine Ahnung.
Das war keine Absicht.
Das war keine Absicht. Der hat telefoniert.
Also hat er mir das
erklärt. Der hat telefoniert. Hat das gar nicht
richtig mitgekriegt. Hat nur gesehen
dass ihn irgendein komischer Typ von der Seite anspricht.
Hat gemeint jetzt nicht.
Ist weitergelaufen und dann ist ihm nachher gedämmert
dass der ein Messer hatte und irgendwas erzählt hat
mir das ist ein Überfall.
Ja.
Es muss aber auch spät gewesen sein.
In der Unterführung.
Cake müssen es jetzt nicht.
Zeit für Überfall.
Gut in der Ecke ist doch auch diese Drogen
Ausgabestelle für Abhängige.
Deswegen hängen
da auch so viele rum.
Ja das stimmt schon.
In Frankfurt war es halt nie so.
Köln Frankfurt.
Senior Frontend
Entwickler.
Developer.
MWD.
Muss mal kurz ein neues Fenster aufmachen.
Sonst blick ich nicht mehr durch.
Warum geht
mein Dark Theme nicht?
Wait a minute.
Ich habe ein Inkognito
Fenster aufgemacht.
Lul.
Taunusanlage in Neuss.
Generell muss man sagen
so gemimt Frankfurt heute auch
wird Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Früher war das deutlich schlimmer.
Ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Mein Vater hatte ein Büro.
Nicht so weit weg davon.
Also
ein ganzes Haus oder so.
Ein gemietetes Büro.
Da sind wir öfters lang gelaufen.
Und da waren richtig wilde
Leute am Start.
Also in den 90ern war Frankfurt noch
deutlich heftiger was das angeht.
Mittlerweile ist es immer noch eklig.
Mittlerweile ist Frankfurt eigentlich
zum größten Teil nur noch eklig.
Aber nicht mehr
assi eklig.
Und dreckig halt.
Nicht mehr so
wie es in den 90ern war.
Das war schon
deutlich heftiger noch.
Deutschsprachiger Kundenberater
inklusive Umzugspaket
nach Bulgarien.
What the fuck?
Also eine Sache die in Frankfurt tatsächlich
besser geworden ist.
Angeblich.
Früher muss hier
auf dieser Ecke
die Kaiserstraße hier
Früher war das hier
fast nur Rotlicht.
Das kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Da war ich klein.
Das weiß ich. Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest jetzt ist es hier noch ein bisschen in der Ecke.
Zumindest früher muss das
die halbe Kaiserstraße gewesen sein.
Und auch ein bisschen in die Münchnerstraße rein.
So und
mittlerweile
ist die Ecke hier vorne echt
ganz umgänglich. Und wisst ihr warum?
Weil hier alles voller
Restaurants, Supermärkte,
Friseure, Kiosks und
sowas ist. Und die haben einfach
überall ihre Security
Leute am Start. Das siehst du auch teilweise.
Du hast halt
Supermarkt mit
Security und sowas. Die gucken
einfach, dass dort
keine schrägen Leute
abhängen. Weil sonst will ja bei ihnen keiner
rein.
Tatsächlich, dass hier das ganze
Rotlichtzeug weg ist in Frankfurt.
Das hat dazu
geführt, dass es deutlich besser
geworden ist in der Ecke. Hier oben rum
ist es halt immer noch richtig
mies. Ja, muss auch mal sein.
Das stimmt wohl.
Ich bin mir
nicht sicher. Ist das das Ding, wo so ein
Restaurant drin ist?
Dann war ich da nur einmal.
Ist das das gleiche?
Seit wann sind wir
dann bei der Bundesagentur für Arbeit am
Start für Stellenanzeigen?
Ja, das stimmt.
Na klar.
Dieter, danke für den Sub.
Alter, ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung.
Ich esse quasi
nie Currywurst.
Der einzige Laden,
wo ich jemals Currywurst
gegessen habe in Frankfurt
ist Donnerstars
auf der
Kaiserstraße,
wo es so Marktstände gab
früher. Und da gab es den Laden, der hatte
Currywurst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das heute noch gibt,
aber ich war da bestimmt schon 10 Jahre nicht mehr.
Nee, das ist zu weit.
Das ist zu weit zum Joggen.
Okay, dann
lasst uns doch mal schauen. Was haben wir
denn hier schönes empfohlen
bekommen vom Chat?
Ein Java-Programm.
Also Leute, wir sind ja selten bei der
Agentur für Arbeit unterwegs.
Mal gucken, wie da die Stellenanzeigen so sind.
Ich meine, es sind die gleichen Stellenanzeigen
wie woanders auch, aber es ist halt die
Agentur für Arbeit, was auch immer.
Zwei Tage kriege ich den Prime-Sub. Das ist
exzellent, Xaito.
Pog. Muss mal schauen,
nicht, dass ich wieder die Hälfte vergessen habe.
Stream-Manager.
Triton hat subscribed.
Dan2Death hat subscribed.
Sonst habe ich nichts übersehen.
Sehr schön.
Pog, uh. Also,
was haben wir denn hier schönes?
Hotel Scholz.
Programmierer.
Männlich-Weiß-Deutsch.
Java.
Ach, Teilzeit.
Moment, was
zum... Aber das muss schon
äußerst wenig Teilzeit sein
dann, oder?
Zwei Stunden Teilzeit, ja.
Quasi
einen Tag die Woche oder so.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Das muss schon wenig Teilzeit sein, oder?
Also, lass uns mal gucken.
Wir suchen
Programmierer-Entwickler zur Weiterentwicklung
und Wartung
unserer bestehenden Gebäudesteuerung
auf EIP-KMX-Basis.
Ich weiß
nicht, was das ist.
Ja, KNX kenne ich.
Aber
KMX?
Oh, guck mal, die haben noch mehr als...
Also, ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Die meinen safe KNX.
Ja, KNX würde auch zur
Gebäudesteuerung passen, weil das genau
für sowas da ist.
Was sie erwartet...
Moment, lass uns doch mal checken.
Wo ist denn das?
Koblenz am Rhein. Wir gucken mal nachher gleich,
wo Hotel Scholz ist.
Entwurf und Implementierung
von Komponenten
unseres neuen
Intranet-Systems auf Basis
auf der Basis
von Java Enter mit viel
Eigenverantwortung.
Hä?
Ich denke, sie wollen die Gebäudesteuerung,
nicht das Intranet. Kann man ja mal nebenbei auch mitmachen.
Kein Problem. Unterstützung und
Realisierung von xWiki.
Leute, ich weiß nicht, was xWiki ist.
xWiki. Advanced
Open Source Enterprise.
Eww.
Okay, das wird auf jeden Fall
aktiv entwickelt.
Leute, taugt das was?
Ist das auf Shithub?
xWiki GitHub.
xWiki Plattform.
Java.
Auf Java Basis. Java.
Nicht auf JavaScript.
Einfach Java.
Okay, irgendein Java
basiertes Wiki.
Ja, warum nicht?
SQL-Kenntnisse.
Jetzt kommen wieder die ersten
Sachen. Nein, Max, es ist SQL.
Wisst ihr, ich bin froh,
dass es SCSI
nicht mehr gibt.
Darüber hat man ja früher manchmal Sachen
angeschlossen.
Und, ähm...
Manche sprechen
es Skazi aus.
Skazi?
Und manche
sagen S-C-S-I.
Ich persönlich war
Fraktion S-C-S-I.
Aber das hat sich
erledigt. Die Zeit hat das Problem
gelöst. Das gibt es einfach nicht mehr.
Okay.
Was? Moment.
Teufer gehende?
Also mal zumindest
Probelesen könnte man die Stellenanzeige
vielleicht.
Ich bin ja normalerweise nicht der Rechtschreibnazi,
der da überall abgeht, auf jeden
Platz drauf springt. Da fehlt ein Komma oder so.
Groß- und Kleinschreibung. Ich
hab's weder mit Kommas noch mit Groß- und Kleinschreibung.
Aber bei einer Stellenanzeige könnte man
zumindest gucken, dass die Wörter richtig beschrieben sind.
Tiefergreifende Kenntnisse
im Bereich Hardware und Server-Hardware.
Okay.
Eventuell.
Das wissen sie doch nicht so genau.
Wartung und Weiterentwicklung
unserer bestehenden Intranet-Anwendung.
Das steht doch hier oben
schon.
Das ist ja
eine geile Stellenanzeige.
Hier oben schreiben sie, du bastelst am neuen
Intranet-System mit.
Ach Moment.
Ich bin PPGa, nicht die Stellenanzeige
ist PPGa.
Hier entwickelt man am neuen Intranet-System mit.
Hier unten bastelt man
am bestehenden Intranet-System
mit.
Das heißt, sie haben zwei Intranet-Systeme,
parallel an denen entwickelt wird.
Das heißt nichts Gutes.
Unterstützung bei der Installation,
Konfiguration und Instandhaltung
neuer Hardware und Software-Systeme.
Leute, ihr sucht einen fucking Java-Entwickler
in Teilzeit, der irgendwie eine Stunde
am Tag da ist oder so.
Entspannt euch
mal ein bisschen.
Der kann nicht noch IT-Support machen
nebenbei.
Also mal davon abgesehen, passt das eh nicht zusammen.
Gegebenenfalls
Unterstützung bei der Weiterentwicklung
der eigenen
Gebäudesteuerung mittels
Ach hier steht KNX.
Von den vollautomatischen
Tiefkühlsteuerung mit Totmann-Schaltung
über Tagungsraum
mit Kalender-Anbindung
bis hin zu sich selbst
Regeln in Hotelzimmern.
Leute, ernsthaft, ich glaube
das hier ist schon ein Vollzeitjob für
sich. Zumal es hier
nicht einfach nur random drauf ankommt,
dass du ein bisschen Java von dir gibst,
sondern dass du eben was
Reliable, dass du
irgendwas produzierst, auf das man sich
verlassen kann. Weil es hat
sicherlich keiner Bock, dass Müll
programmiert wird, dass dann die Tiefkühlsteuerung
abspackt oder die Hotelzimmer
auf 60 Grad heizen.
Wahrscheinlich musste dann auch noch,
wenn ich mir die Stellenanzeigen so angucke,
musste wahrscheinlich dann auch noch in die Hotelzimmer
und selbst die Elektronik
anklemmen.
Könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, weil ich meine,
du machst ja was mit Technik als Programmierer.
Da kann man das doch auch machen.
Ich speichere mir das mal.
Das ist eine nice Stellenanzeige.
Vielleicht bist du auch noch Hausmeister.
Und das für 1050...
Ja, easy. Moment, Teilzeit.
Du bist halt
zwei Stunden da.
Geht halt nicht so schnell alles.
Arbeiten
auf hohem technischen Niveau.
Lösung von der Stange reizen
wissen wir meist bis Maximum aus.
Daher sind viele Dinge Eigenentwicklungen.
Man könnte auch
bösartig reininterpretieren. Wir wissen nicht,
was wir so genau treiben.
Must have
Sehr gute Kenntnisse in Java-Programmierung.
Gute analytische
Fähigkeiten
zum Nachvollziehen komplexer Automatismen.
Sehr gute
Kenntnisse in XML.
Please, no.
No, god!
Please, no!
XML.
Alles auf Soap-Basis wahrscheinlich noch.
Sehr gute
Kenntnisse in HTML5-Technologien.
HTML5, CSS3,
JavaScript und
Ajax.
Ist jetzt ein bisschen random dabei.
Aber gut.
Ja, gut.
Web-Requests machen, kommst nicht drum herum.
Also.
Alles klar. Ich habe bis jetzt
zwar noch nichts von Frontend gesehen,
aber anscheinend
muss man auch Frontend machen.
Neba SQL,
Java, neues und altes
Intranet und Gebäudeautomatisierung
und Support für Hard- und Software.
Geil.
So.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Selbstständiges, ergebnisorientiertes
Arbeiten und die Fähigkeit von konkreten Problemen
und so blablabla. Sehr gute
Kenntnisse in SQL.
Eclipse.
Also, wenn jetzt irgendjemand noch Bock
darauf gehabt hat, ist das jetzt spätestens
vorbei.
Oh Gott!
Eclipse.
Spätestens
jetzt ist es vorbei.
Ich glaube,
der Stellenanzeigen-Ersteller
leckt critical information.
Oder wie seht ihr das?
Ich glaube, die meinen
es gut. Sie wissen es aber
nicht besser. Das ist nicht einfach
nur Full-Stack, Leute.
Das ist nicht nur Full-Stack, das ist
wirklich Complete-Stack. Du machst
ja auch noch Hardware
und Software
Support konfiguriert. Du machst ja auch noch
Client Support dabei.
Erfahrung mit Multithreading
und Thread-Synchronisation
in Java. Okay.
Das ist aber äußerst speziell. Ich würde
sagen, jeder gute Java-Entwickler weiß,
wie man Multithreading in Java entwickelt.
Fähigkeiten sich in
Ein Bestehendes, wahrscheinlich etwas mehr
einzuarbeiten.
Nice to have. Erfahrung
im Umgang mit
Xn... Leute, die
Stellenanzeige... Was ist
ETS4?
Okay, irgendwelche KNX-Geschichten.
Wisst ihr, ich hätte jetzt ja
vermutet, dass Erfahrung
im Umgang mit KNX
eigentlich ein absolutes
Must-Have ist, wenn sie
einen Entwickler suchen für die
Gebäudesteuerung mit KNX.
Okay, sorry, KNX.
Also, das widerspricht
sich ein bisschen. Die suchen explizit jemanden dafür
in der Überschrift, aber dann drunter ist
es nur nice to have.
Eintrittsdatum ab morgen.
Ja, endlich! Let's go,
Leute!
Die meinen KNX.
Das ist so ein Gebäudeautomatisierungs-
Bussystem. Das haben viele
auch, die ein neues Haus bauen
oder renovieren. Für Heimautomatisierung
wird das verlegt.
Äh... EEP?
Der Chat sagt, KNX hieß früher mal
EEP. Ich glaub das dem Chat einfach.
Weil ihr wisst, dass der Chat prinzipiell
way too smart ist.
Und jeder Primesub alle
IQ-Punkte erhöht.
Deswegen kann der Chat eigentlich nicht falsch liegen
bei sowas. Nein, Teilzeit!
Bis zu 1500 Euro
pro Tor.
Wir reden
jetzt hier von was, wo du noch Steuern
drauf bezahlen musst. Das heißt, okay,
du bezahlst dann nicht die Hälfte davon an Steuern.
Sagen wir mal, du hast bei
diesem Gehalt
am Ende noch 1100
Euro übrig. Ich bin mir
da nicht sicher, wie die Steuern so genau sind.
Hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen davon ab, was du sonst noch so bekommst.
Sagen wir mal, du hast 1100 Euro
oder so noch übrig. Das ist dann
fast Azubi-Gehalt quasi.
Aber ich mein,
die bekommen davon sicherlich jemand
in Teilzeit. Der ist dann aber halt
eine Stunde am Tag oder so da.
Oder halt,
sagen wir mal so, einen halben Tag
die Woche ist der da.
Ich werd das gleich öffnen.
Chat-Gehalt.
Okay. Lass uns
jetzt noch mal fertig gucken.
Erfahrung mit Apache
Cocoon. Ich weiß nicht, was
das ist.
Spring-Based Framework.
Was sonst?
Erfahrung mit serverseitigem Javascript.
Node.js.
Dachtet ihr, Backend ist mit Java?
Aber wir machen
jetzt auch...
Erfahrung mit Modbus
oder sicherer Umgang mit Bitwise-Operationen.
Hat irgendjemand
eine Ahnung gehabt, der die Stellenanzeige
geschrieben hat, was er da reinschreibt?
Jetzt ernst gemeinte Frage.
Also ich mein,
es ist schon äußerst speziell,
irgendwelche Bitshift-Sachen da
reinzuschreiben.
Ich mein, ein ordentlicher Programmierer weiß,
wie man das benutzt und
wenn man es braucht, dann kann er es auch verwenden.
Meistens braucht man es ja glücklicherweise nicht.
Okay, vielleicht Low-Level
Modbus-Geschichten.
Aber das liest sich sehr
weird irgendwie.
Das hat doch bestimmt
die Personalabteilung geschrieben,
ohne irgendwie Plan zu haben,
um was es da eigentlich geht, oder?
Was wir sonst noch bieten?
Fundierte fachliche Einweisung.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, da können die jetzt nichts für.
Aber
ich hab's schon ein paar Mal gesagt
in diesen Videos und ich hab auch schon
vom Chat andere Sichtweisen
gehört, aber ich finde immer noch,
dass das ordentliche Einarbeiten
eines neuen Mitarbeiters
im
ureigensten Interesse des jeweiligen
Unternehmens
liegen sollte
und das eigentlich kein
krasser Benefit ist.
Wenn die dich nicht einarbeiten,
bekommen sie nichts für ihr Geld.
Also, die wären blöd,
wenn sie dich nicht einarbeiten. Deswegen
weiß ich nicht, warum das immer so als
Benefit hingestellt wird. Aber
andere Sichtweise war, letztens hat mir jemand
im Chat geschrieben, er finde das
gut, dass das jemand reinschreibt in die
Stellenanzeige, weil
da weiß man wenigstens, dass sie sich Gedanken drum gemacht haben
und sich drum kümmern und man nicht einfach nur
rumhockt. Verstehe ich auch.
Ich denke halt, das ist kein Benefit
für mich primär,
sondern hauptsächlich für das Unternehmen,
was mich einarbeitet, dass ich überhaupt
das, was ich koste,
erbringen kann. Wenn sie mich nicht einarbeiten,
wird das halt nichts oder viel langsamer und viel später.
Abwechslungsreiche Tätigkeit.
Ja, das glaube
ich euch, dass es abwechslungsreiche Tätigkeiten
sind, wenn das alles stimmt.
Der Umgang mit ihrer Arbeitszeit inklusive Zeit
konnte in ihrem Urlaub.
Da bin ich ja froh
bei meinem
bei meiner
4-Stunden-Woche.
Bin ich ja froh.
4-Stunden-Woche, easy.
Auf geht's.
Die Möglichkeit,
ja, das ist,
du hast vollkommen recht, so irgendwie
als Zweit-Dritt-Job
wenn man eh schon ausgesorgt hat,
ein bisschen was Sinnvolles nebenbei machen
will, aber dafür passt halt die
Riesenanzahl an Tätigkeiten nicht dazu.
Die Möglichkeit,
nach der Einarbeitung teils auch von Hause
auszuarbeiten
zu können, zum Beispiel der Remote-Desktop
mit weitgehend Freiheit.
Okay, immerhin versuchen sie
sowas wie Homeoffice
zu schreiben. Sie schreiben teils,
in dem Fall muss ich sagen, ich verstehe
das sogar, dass diese Stelle
nicht, dass man da nicht groß wirbt
mit Homeoffice, weil wenn es wirklich
hauptsächlich darum geht, in irgendwelchen
Hotelzimmern und Gebäudesteuerungen
Modbus-Geschichten zu machen,
könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das Sachen
sind, wo man echt öfters vor Ort
mal was ausprobieren muss.
Sollten sie unsere Anforderungen erfüllen können,
bitte keine
Bewerbungsmape per Post einsenden.
Jetzt hab ich's auch knacken gehört
im Headset gerade, yo.
Bitte keine telefonische oder persönliche
Bewerbung. Okay.
Ja, E-Mail ist schon
okay. Ich würde
da auch nix... Schreibt man
Betrefffeld so? Ich glaube schon, oder?
Neue Rechtschreibung, FTW.
Betreff-Feld.
Ich hätte es mit 2F nur geschrieben,
aber...
ergibt schon Sinn, neue Rechtschreibungsmäßig.
Schifffahrt
3F, so.
Bitte setzen sie
das Betreff-Feld,
das Wort Bewerbung,
den Titel, der Stelle
und ihren Namen. Bitte senden sie dem Anschreiben
mindestens eine Lebensaufgabe her.
Eine kurze
Beschreibung, bisherige Probleme,
falls vorhanden, auch Handynummer derart.
Übernachtungsmöglichkeiten können wir keinen zur Verfügung stellen.
Ihr seid doch ein fucking
Hotel, alter!
Na gut. Ich weiß ja nicht,
Leute, also...
Das ist wieder so ein typische
Stellenanzeige
in einem Unternehmen, was wahrscheinlich
übelst über
Fachkräftemangel überall am
sich aufregen ist und nicht versteht,
warum sie keine finden.
Und warum dann in der Arbeitsamtstatistik
auftaucht, unbesetzte Stelle, wir haben noch
mehr Mangel.
Ich will denen aber mal gar nicht unterstellen,
bevor das jetzt zu böse klingt,
dass sie das so
meinen, wie es hier steht.
Ich glaube einfach,
die müssten sich echt mal hinsetzen
und eine gute Stellenanzeige schreiben.
Oder irgendjemand
eine erstellen lassen.
Weil es könnte durchaus sein, dass das Unternehmen
gar nicht
so mies ist.
Aber anhand der Stellenanzeige,
anhand der Stellenbeschreibung,
da würde ich
nicht nur eine Armlänge Abstand von halten,
da würde ich wirklich einen ganz großen
Bogen drum machen.
Lass uns doch mal kurz die Bewertung von Hotel Scholz
in Koblenz angucken.
Alter, ich habe
Comonbra auf dem Shortcut noch.
Ich benutze das Emote so gut wie nie.
Warum habe ich das auf dem Shortcut?
Okay, naja.
Comonbru.
Hotel
Scholz in Koblenz.
Scheint gute Bewertungen
zu haben. Ja, Bewertungen sind glaube ich
von Hotel ganz okay.
Aber
wir können ja mal gucken, haben die irgendwie
Konunu oder sowas? Ich glaube so groß sind.
Schulz Hotel Scholz.
So viele haben die nicht.
Wisst ihr, was ich vermute? Ich glaube
auch, dass man der einzige ITler ist, den die
haben, oder? Was denkt ihr?
Meint ihr, die haben noch mehr?
Für mich liegt das so, als ist
der letzte abgehauen und die suchen jetzt halt wieder jemand.
Wer soll dich denn da einarbeiten?
Egal, das schreiben die halt
mal hin. Schau auf deren
Internetseite. Okay.
Hotel Scholz
Koblenz. Lasst mal gucken.
Ähm, hier.
Achtung, Flashbang.
Leute. Och nee, ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Seite. Ich dank Mut.
Die Vollzeitstelle hat auf Teilzeit
gewechselt. Du bist die andere Hälfte davon.
Du bist aber eine ziemlich schmale andere Hälfte
davon bei 1500 Euro
brutto. Du bist ja nur 4 Stunden die Woche da.
Haben die
hier auch einen Job?
Ist das ein
WordPress-Template, Leute?
Woher
erkenne ich am besten
ob das ein WordPress-Template ist?
Es ist WordPress, oder?
WP-Content.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, Leute.
Wir gehen jetzt nicht auf WP-Admin und gucken, was da los ist.
Das machen wir nicht. Kein Hackermans-Zeug hier im Stream.
Sonst wann?
Ja. Gut, dementsprechend
sieht die Webseite natürlich auch ganz brauchbar aus, weil WordPress.
Gut. Ich will jetzt nicht zu lange
drauf rumreiten.
Ich würde ihnen aber persönlich
doch empfehlen
eine ansprechendere Stellenanzeige
zu erstellen, weil
eventuell
ist das Unternehmen ganz okay,
aber das kommt dann aus der Stellenanzeige
echt nicht raus und wir können hier nur das beurteilen
und die Bewerber
sehen ja auch nur das. Es ist umgedreht, ja
genauso und
also da wirkt es
nicht wie was, wo sich irgendjemand,
der auch nur annähernd ein bisschen was kann,
bewirbt heutzutage. Okay.
Hätten wir das
nächst.
Was haben wir denn hier? Nochmal. Komm.
Wir gucken jetzt mal
noch die zwei. Übrigens Leute, sorry, falls
ihr irgendwas übersehen habt,
wenn noch jemand Stellenanzeigen hat,
zum angucken, dann nur her damit.
Wie bist du bei den... Achso, ich muss mal
kurz hier Chat gelesen.
Okay, weiter hoch kann ich nicht mehr.
Wie bist du
bei Jobangebote immer vorgegangen? Hast du
aus dem Bauch heraus entschieden oder hast du
die Vor- und Nachteile aufgewogen und dann entschieden?
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich
musste noch nicht so oft entscheiden.
Meine Ausbildung
habe ich... Also, eine
zweite. Ich nenne es die Ausbildung.
Ihr kennt meine BWL
Exkurs Story. Vergessen wir das
einfach. Meine Ausbildung
habe ich nach
der... Weiß ich nicht.
Nicht mal
eine handvoll Bewerbungen gefunden.
Hab dann auch sofort zugesagt.
Also, ich hab mich Tag später angerufen, hab sofort unterschrieben.
Gut war.
Danach bin ich...
Nach der Ausbildung bin ich dort geblieben
noch kurz und bin
dann von dort zu einem Unternehmen
gewechselt,
die ich schon kannte
von
meiner Arbeit beim Provider.
Das heißt, da musste ich
weder groß bewerben,
noch war
das irgendwie große Überlegung.
Die haben gesagt, Max, willst du nicht zu uns?
Bei uns
ist eh alles besser und du kriegst auch
mehr Kohle. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ja.
Und dann war das fertig.
Und als die mir dann auf den Keks gegangen sind,
hab ich letztes Jahr angefangen,
mich nach einem neuen Job umzugucken.
Das lief so,
dass mich ein
ehemaliger Kollege angeschrieben hat,
ob ich
nicht zu ihnen will.
Hab ich gesagt, ja, nice.
Erzähl mal.
Dann war ich dann dort,
hab mir das angeguckt, mit dem Team gesprochen,
waren uns einig.
Die haben mir einen Vertrag zugeschickt.
Kurz bevor ich den Vertrag
bekommen habe und unterschreiben
wollte,
hat mich ein anderer ehemaliger Kollege
aus Frankfurt
angeschrieben und hat gefragt, Max,
willst du nicht lieber zu uns?
Hab ich gesagt, ja, klingt gut. Erzähl mal.
Ein paar Tage später
bin ich da hingefahren,
hab drei Stunden
Vorstellungsgespräch gemacht
und bin dort am Ende rausgegangen
mit einem super Eindruck, mit einer guten Kombination
aus ordentlich
mehr Kohle,
super Homeoffice-Regelung
und alles andere
auch einen ganz guten Eindruck. Und dann hab ich halt das
von den zwei Sachen unterschrieben.
Fertig.
Drei Stunden, ja.
Aber das drei Stunden Vorstellungsgespräch
setzt sich ja auch nicht aus drei Stunden, ich werde gelöchert
zusammen. Das war eigentlich nur für zwei Stunden
geplant, aber das ging dann drei Stunden.
Aus folgendem Grund,
als erstes Drittel oder so
wurde ich halt ausgefragt
nach den üblichen Geschichten.
Was müssten wir machen, um sie so richtig zu ärgern?
Welche Tipps würden sie
einer Führungskraft geben?
Ach, keine Ahnung, solche Dinge.
Ein paar typische
Vorstellungsgespräche fragen.
Ein paar
andere Punkte besprechen. Danach konnte ich noch
ein bisschen was fragen und eigentlich haben wir uns
wirklich
soweit gut verstanden und waren uns auch
einig. Ich hab auch gleich gefragt, wie es mit Homeoffice aussieht
und sonst wie bla bla blub.
Waren wir uns einig und
ja, dass es dann drei Stunden
gedauert hat,
lag daran, dass wir
beide am Anfang gesagt haben,
wir entscheiden uns heute nicht.
Ich hab das gesagt und die haben das auch gesagt.
Wir entscheiden uns heute nicht, wir müssen uns
danach noch kurz Gedanken machen.
Und ich hab das auch
gesagt. Also heute weiß ich nicht, ob ich
dazusagen kann, weil ich muss mir das erst nochmal überlegen.
Und nach den zwei Stunden
haben wir gesagt, okay, eigentlich finden
wir das doch nice, wollen wir jetzt nochmal kurz über das Geld reden.
Und dementsprechend haben wir dann
nochmal 45 Minuten über Gehalt und sonstige
Sachen gelabert und deswegen ging das
quasi drei Stunden.
Und nachdem wir uns dann einig waren,
was Homeoffice, Gehalt
und alles angeht, hab ich gesagt, okay, passt.
Das einzige, was ich brauche von euch
ist, ich brauche
irgendwas Handfestes, weil
ich hab noch einen anderen Vertrag daheim liegen
und ich muss
kündigen bis 31.12.
und das war
kurz vor Weihnachten, als ich da war
mit dem Gespräch. Und da haben
sie gesagt, ja, also Max, wir können dir
eine vorläufige
Zusage schicken, die gilt
außer der Betriebsrat widerspricht
noch, aber das ist noch nie vorgekommen.
Ja, und da hab ich mich dann darauf eingelassen.
Da haben sie mir das geschickt
und, also, dass
das bindend ist außer der Betriebsrat
stimmt noch
oder sagt das ab, was die hier wohl nicht machen.
Und
dann hab ich unterschrieben, kurz
vor Weihnachten und dann war gut.
Also so sah es mit meinen Bewerbungen aus.
Ich hab nicht die krasse
Bewerbungserfahrung,
was ich gemacht habe für den aktuellen Job,
ich hab eine Bewerbung schreiben müssen,
weil das der
Workflow so vorsieht. Ich hab also eine Bewerbung
geschrieben, dahin geschickt
und dann hat mich
mein Chef, also mein
Chef, den ich da jetzt hab,
hat mich quasi, keine Ahnung,
paar Stunden,
nachdem ich das abgeschickt hab,
angerufen, da war ich grad im Bauhaus
einen Weihnachtsbaum kaufen.
Kannst du die Zensier zeigen? Ja,
mach ich. Wollte ich schon lange
in einem Video zeigen. Also so sieht das,
so sah das bei mir mit den Bewerbungen aus. Also ich kann
dir das nicht so wirklich,
das eine hat halt
total überwogen.
Die andere Firma war in Würzburg.
Die haben mir zwar sehr viel Homeoffice zugesagt,
aber man weiß ja nicht, wie es auf Dauer
ist. Also,
ich war,
die anderen hatten halt wirklich die Vorteile.
Die waren in Frankfurt, haben richtig gut
bezahlt, hatten eine super Homeoffice-Regelung,
größeres Unternehmen,
was man kennt,
Finanzbranche Frankfurt,
man kommt super hin.
Die hatten halt wirklich mehr
zu bieten in dem Fall. Da gab es nicht groß
zu überlegen. Nein, das ist nicht
die Sparkasse.
Zwei ehemalige Kollegen,
die sind bei der Sparkasse
jetzt. Und die meinen, da ist auch
alles sehr bürokratisch.
So, Chat, wenn ich irgendwas übersehen hab, dann
AdWords bloß, ihr wisst ja.
Essen. Genauso wie jetzt auch.
Ja, es gibt ja viele solcher
bescheuerten Bewerbungsfragen, so nach dem Motto
Füllen sie, füllen
sie ein Fiat 500e mit Smarties?
Wie würden
sie ein Fiat 500e mit, nee,
wie viele Smarties brauchen sie,
um ein Fiat 500e zu füllen?
Und solche Fragen, ja.
Fuck, Alter, was ist mit euch los?
Ich installiere mir erstmal einen Kubernetes-Cluster
dafür, der die Smarties verteilt.
Ich habe auf solche Fragen immer
keine Antwort, es sei denn,
ich bin gerade im Bewerbungsmodus.
Ansonsten sind das so Dinger, da
geht ins eine Ohr rein, ins andere raus.
Also,
die einzig lustige Frage war tatsächlich,
ähm,
was müssten wir machen, dass sie so richtig
ärgert?
Und daraufhin, hab ich euch ja schon erzählt,
daraufhin hab ich gesagt, Windows administrieren.
Aber ansonsten war das eigentlich
nicht der Rede wert, so.
Okay, weiter
geht's. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Also, was
haben wir denn hier jetzt Schönes?
Deutschsprachiger, übrigens Leute, falls
ich irgendwelche Stellenanzeigen übersehen hab,
schickt sie nochmal, ich komm im Chat nicht mehr weiter
hoch, haut sie einfach rein, wenn
ich mir das angucken soll. Und wie gesagt,
es geht hier nicht darum,
nur Kack-Stellenanzeigen zu zeigen.
Ich zeig auch gerne gute Stellenanzeigen.
Das heißt, wenn ihr irgendwas habt,
von, äh, von euch, wo ihr euch
bewerben wollt, oder
von der Firma, wo ihr arbeitet,
ich geb da gerne meinen Senf dazu.
Wenn ich mal
irgendwelche Sachen mir nicht davon angucken
soll, dann schreibt's dabei.
Ich hab irgendeine, ich hab irgendeine Motte
oder so hier rumfliegen, übelst weird
Champ, die fliegt mir die ganze Zeit gegen's Bein und ich
erwisch sie nicht. Einer auf HR
in Bewerbungsgesprächen, wenn's um Technik
komplett verzichtet wird, nein,
HR-Leute sollten eigentlich immer dabei sein.
Also, finde ich persönlich. Natürlich
könntest du sagen, wenn's um technische Sachen geht, ja.
Und wenn's nur um die, wenn nur die technische
Seite beleuchtet werden soll, aber wenn's
um die Gestaltung deines Arbeitsvertrages
mitgeht, dann sollte schon einer von
HR dabei sein. Gerade auch, wenn du
spezielle Fragen hast, so, wie ist
das, wie, wie ist das mit Urlaub, wie wird das
so und so geplant, wie ist das, die
Zahlung bei dem und dem, das kann, das
kann euch HR besser beantworten.
Zeiterfassung oder Ausgleich von
Mehrarbeit mit, ne, hab ich, hab ich noch.
Doch, hab ich!
Ey, sag mal, ne, ne,
am Rande, am Rande, ne Story
dazu passt, ist auch,
ist auch nicht, ist auch nicht lang.
Mein ehemaliger Chef,
der nicht mehr mein, mein
Chef ist, logischerweise, weil's
mein ehemaliger Chef, der aber auch nicht mehr bei dem Unternehmen
arbeitet, wo er mein Chef war,
der
wurde mal
in eine andere Stadt
geschickt, in ein Rechenzentrum
und
war da den ganzen Tag
zu, zu Gange im Rechenzentrum
und musste dann dort
übernachten, obwohl das eigentlich
kürzer geplant war
und dann ist er,
ist er von der Arbeit halt im Rechenzentrum
ist der ins Hotel gemeint, ist ins Bett
gefallen, war übelst kaputt, wahrscheinlich
auch jegliche Arbeitszeitvorschrift und sonst was
gerissen und hat sich
dann abends, hatte keinen Bock mehr irgendwie
großartig was zu holen und hat dann
im Hotel einen Orangensaft getrunken
aus der Minibar für irgendwie
1,50 oder sowas
und da hat dann die
Abrechnungsstelle bei uns
damals auf der Arbeit übel Stress gemacht
dass sie die 1,50 für den
für den Orangensaft nicht bezahlen
weil das wär ja nicht mit
dabei und auch nicht geplant und was soll
dass er überhaupt Orangensaft da trinkt
echt jetzt, ja, echt
das ist halt echt nicht normal
gewesen, was da teilweise abgegangen ist
die IHK ist so realitätsfern
Moment, ich muss mir das erstmal
in der Vorschau angucken
Ja, das, einen kleinen
Ausschnitt kann ich im Stream zeigen, das ist
glaube ich kein Problem
gucken wir uns gleich an
ich guck's mir ja nur an, ne, du hast
ja gepostet, kek
also lasst uns mal kurz hier das
anreizen, was haben wir denn hier schönes
was möchte denn das Arbeitsamt
schmackhaft machen?
deutschsprachiger Kundenberater
MWD inklusive Umzugspaket
nach Bulgarien
das Kompetenz
Call Center Duisburg
oh ja, das klingt ja nach einer ganz tollen Geschichte
ergreife deine Chance
und erfinde dich neu
das ist halt, das ist quasi
Outsourcing
um Umzisourcing
sowas in der Richtung
also die Outsourcen nehmen aber Leute mit
Transfer Sourcing
sorry for bash, dankeschön
für den Sub, hast du mal überlegt
in Cyber Security zu wechseln? Nö
ich mein bisschen Sicherheit
ist selbstverständlich auch im Lehnungsumfeld
wichtig
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich genug Skills
habe als krasser Security Dude
ok, werde Teil unseres
Teams im Herzen Europas
erlebe nach Feierabend
den historischen Kern von
Loftif
ok
oder die modernen
ich will nach Feierabend meine Ruhe
zusammen mit deinen Kollegen
genieße das milde Klima
deutschsprachiger Kundenberater
wir bieten dir komplettes
Relocation Paket
wir übernehmen Flugtransferunterkunft
konsumiere die Suche nach einer langfristigen Mietzuschuss
verdiene weit über dem nationalen Durchschnitt
bei niedrigen Lebenshaltungskosten
das ist tatsächlich
wahr, in der Stelle könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen
die Lebenshaltungskosten
sind in Bulgarien
sicherlich deutlich niedriger als hier
und wenn die auch nur ansatzweise
bezahlen wie hier, verdienst du da richtig krass
Geld wahrscheinlich für das Umfeld
monatliches
Guthaben für flexible Benefits
google mal nationaler
Durchschnitt Bulgarien
Bulgarien
1000 Dollar
also wenn sie ordentlich was bezahlen, dann kannst du da wirklich
richtig auf dicke Hose
machen, wenn man sowas machen möchte
also hast du auf jeden Fall ordentlich Geld, zusätzliche Krankenversicherung
krisensicherer Job, top Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
Zugang zum Firmen
eigene Fitnessstudio
Telus Tower
Deutschkenntnisse
Englischkenntnisse
Microsoft Office
ganz ehrlich
ich
also für mich
ist es halt überhaupt
gar nichts sowas
es ist weder IT noch hätte ich
Bock irgendwie
nach Bulgarien zu gehen
aber
aber ernsthaft
warum habe ich jetzt eins copypasted
ich meine so
so blöde ist das
doch gar nicht für Leute, die
die vielleicht echt
hier weg wollen, ich meine, warum nicht
also, ja
man weiß halt wenig dazu
also, next
jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal
die Sachen an, die der Max gepostet hat
was sehen wir denn hier
überhaupt, ah, eine IHK Abschlussprüfung
Prüfung
ne, eine Ausbilderprüfung
von der IHK
ok
ich hasse IHK Prüfungen
wenn ich das schon sehe, habe ich keinen Bock
also, was haben die hier
Ausbildung der Ausbilder von der IHK
Ausgangssituation
Sie sollen eine Unterweisung zum Thema
fachgerechtes Handhaben von
Wachsgeräten durchführen
alter
ich fass es nicht
ok, es geht hier halt ums Prinzip
hier nicht, es ist ja eigentlich wahrscheinlich egal
ob Faxgeräte, aber
ist das, ist das was aktuelles
oder ist das von 2005 oder wie
Sie sollen eine Unterweisung zum Thema
fachgerechtes Handhaben von
Faxgeräten durchführen
und dabei
die Sozialkompetenz
der zwei Auszubildenden fördern
das ist aktuell, ok
für das vorhandene Faxgerät
steht eine ausführliche Beschreibung zur Verfügung
bei der Unterweisungsplanung
beziehen Sie sich auf die Ausbildungsordnung
für den Ausbildungsberuf
dort finden Sie unter anderem
folgende Formulierung
oh ne, äh
muss ich das lesen
ähm
die in dieser Rechtsverordnung genannten
Fertigkeiten und Kenntnisse sollen so vermittelt werden
dass der Auszubildende zur Ausübung
einer qualifizierten beruflichen Tätigkeit
befähigt wird, die insbesondere
selbstständiges Plandurchführen
einschließt
Ausbildungsrahmenplan
betriebliche Arbeitsorganisationsmittel
insbesondere Büromaschinen und Geräte fachgerecht
handhaben, ok, jetzt kommt die Frage
jetzt kommt die Frage, also
entscheiden Sie
wie die Formulierungen
in der Ausbildungsordnung zu interpretieren sind
oh ne, das mach ich jetzt nicht
da hab ich keinen Bock drauf
IHK Prüfung hab ich hin, ja mit dem Prüfungsausbilden
ja noch viel schlimmer
wir gucken uns die nächste Aufgabe an
Max, was ist die richtige Antwort
erhelle uns
Anzahl der richtigen Antworten, 3
ok, was haben wir noch
Aufgabe 72
geben Sie an, welche
Lernzielformulierungen
den Absichten der Ausbildungsordnung
entsprechen
die Auszubildenden sollen
das Thema und das Ziel der Unterweisung
nennen können
das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, oder?
wenn ein Azubi weiß, um was es eigentlich
gerade geht
ok, hier ist richtig BCE
ok, nice, aha
die Bedienungsanleitung
verstehen und selbstständig anwenden
können, ja
ich mein
aus IHK Sicht wahrscheinlich schon
ich würde sagen, Sie sollten keine Bedienungsanleitung
mehr brauchen danach
Tomox, danke für den Sub
praktische Fertigkeiten zum Handhaben
des Faxgeräts entwickeln, ja auch
das richtige Handhaben des Faxgeräts
nachmachen können
nachmachen können, alter
was für eine Formulierung
Sie sollten es verstanden haben, am besten Fall
die Richtigkeit
des eigenen Handels bewerten können
wisst ihr, das ist jetzt so ein Ding
das sind so typische IHK Fragen
du musst jetzt
du könntest jetzt instinktiv sagen
ABC, aber du musst dich immer
dran reinversetzen, es ist die IHK
was möchte die IHK denn jetzt hören
Max, was ist richtig bei 72?
BCE
das Thema und das Ziel der Unterweisung
nennen zu können, ist also
nicht wichtig, oder wie?
der Azubi muss nicht wissen, um was es jetzt geht
also man fängt am besten
gleich an zu sagen
ich klicke jetzt auf Tasten ABC
ohne dem Azubi vorher zu sagen, ach übrigens
ich zeig dir jetzt mal das Faxgerät
das klingt natürlich sehr sinnvoll
aber genau so macht es die IHK
ja selber
das ist einfach nur Schrott
was haben wir denn hier sonst schönes
Senior
Frontend Entwickler, Developer
Hamburg, Köln, Bonn
sind das irgendwelche
Personalverschacherer hier
wenn die an so vielen Standorten suchen
werde Teil unseres Teams
wir freuen uns auf dich
we make it
wie viele
innovative Sätze
ich schon mit IT gelesen habe
feierlich
we make IT work
ok, du möchtest mit uns
innovative und zukunftsfähige
IT Lösungen entwickeln
guck mal, hier sieht man eben auch die Bewertung
das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice gemacht
also innovative bla bla bla
wir suchen dich als Senior
Frontend Experte
bist du bereit
mit deinem IT Talent die Welt
des Webdesigns aufzumischen
also mit meinen CSS Skills
würde ich sagen, würde ich
auf jeden Fall die Welt des Webdesigns
aufmischen, ob das Ergebnis
denen gefällt, ja vielleicht
andere Frage
wir suchen berufserfahrene
Frontend Entwickler wie dich
die HTML, CSS und Javascript
im Schlaf beherrschen und die Grenzen
des möglichen überschreiten wollen
wisst ihr was, so ein bisschen
nur halt netter geschrieben erinnert
mich das an die Chat-GPT
Stellenanzeige für
ein Linux Admin
hey, wir suchen einen
verdammt genialen Senior Linux Engineer
der Windows als das Scheißsystem
betrachtet, dass es ist
wenn du ein Linux Guru bist
der jeden Befehl wie ein Boss
beherrscht, dann bist du bei uns genau
richtig, du solltest die Cloud wie die
Rückseite deiner Hand kennen und das Zeug
wie Kubernetes neues Geld besser beherrschen
als deine eigene Muttersprache
wir wollen einen Entwickler der es liebt
agil zu sein und DevSec bis FinOps
in den Griff zu bekommen
aber hey, lass dich nicht von
dieser bescheidenen Stellenbeschreibung einschüchtern
wir suchen nach jemanden der
bereit ist die Schicht 24.7
durchzuarbeiten, ohne Rücksicht
auf Freunde, Familie und andere Verpflichtungen
es ist uns auch egal
ob du verheiratet bist oder Kinder hast
wir wollen jemanden der nur Augen für Linux hat
und die besten Ergebnisse liefert
wenn er allein mit seinem Rechner
in einer dunklen Ecke sitzt
ich finde die
Stellenanzeige
echt gut von
ChatGPT, die könnte man so schalten
und die würde wahrscheinlich
da würden sich wahrscheinlich echt Leute drauf bewerben, weil
sowas ausgefallen ist, ja
was der Prompt war, weiß ich nicht mehr
wir haben ein bisschen rumgebaut bis ChatGPT
sowas ausgespuckt hat
gibt das irgendwie zum Copy-Pasten? Ne
musst du OCR machen
aus dem Stream
die Welt verändern mit
Javascript CSS, ok
aber halt
Chat
das ist noch längst nicht alles
bei uns stehen Qualität
und Sicherheit hoch im Kurs
wenn du bereits damit
vertraut bist, hast du definitiv
einen Vorsprung, das ist noch nicht alles
es geht immer noch weiter
und weißt du was?
wir stehen total auf
automatisiertes Testen von Webanwendungen
wenn du dich also mit den
coolsten Testtools auskennst
dann bist du bei uns genau richtig
ok
ist zwar ein bisschen super hip geschrieben
aber geht in Ordnung
das ist eine gute Idee, aber dazu musst du gar
keinen Operator selbst schreiben
das kannst du ganz einfach machen mit dem
Helloperator für Kubernetes
da kannst du nämlich auf Events
reagieren, so wie Namespaces
created oder sowas in der Richtung
und dann kannst du ein Skript ausführen
lassen, was es für dich macht, da brauchst du gar keinen
eigenen Operator basteln
wir suchen dich als Senior Frontend-Experten
Moment, das hatten wir doch gerade schon
das solltest du mitbringen
wir erwarten von dir, dass du mindestens
ein Javascript-Framework beherrschst
Leute, ich kann sogar zwei
noch ein bisschen Vue
das habe ich schon lange nicht verwendet
egal ob es React, Angular oder
Vue ist, Hauptsache du
schaukelst das Framework
das kannst du mit mindestens zwei Jahren
Berufserfahrung als Frontend-Entwickler nachweisen
und wenn du
auch fundierte Entwicklungserfahrung auf
mobilen Plattformen wie iOS oder Android
und Erfahrung im IT-nahen
Bankenumfeld mitbringst
ja, das ist tatsächlich
mal eine Sache, die ich mitbringe
bist du absolut richtig
bei Syngenio
IO
Syngenio, ich weiß nicht
wie man sie ausspricht
in unserem agilen Team
Teams arbeiten wir mit Scrum
oder Kanban
ich hoffe die arbeiten auch noch safe und in
T-Shaped Teams
Zusammenarbeit, Flexibilität
und natürlich diagonal skalieren
Zusammenarbeit, Flexibilität und
kreative Ideen stehen bei uns
Kommunikation ist das A und O
deshalb solltest du verhandlungssichere Deutschkenntnisse
und sichere Englischkenntnisse
auf dem Kasten haben
außerdem bieten wir Homebase
wähle deinen Standort
ok, ja
choose your own device
egal ob Apple, Google oder Microsoft
solange ich Linux installieren darf
also choose your own device
finde ich ist eine super Geschichte
hätte ich bei mir auf der Arbeit auch gerne
dass ich mir diesen ganzen Windows-Schrott nicht mehr geben muss
aber zum Glück habe ich meine Linux-Kiste
also meine virtuelle Linux-Cloud-Kiste
mit ordentlich Power
stay flexible
ob im Office, Homeoffice oder beim Kunden
arbeite dort
wo du und dein Team produktiv
jetzt muss ich mal kurz sehen
ist das irgendein Personalvermittler
oder was ist das für ein Laden
Beratungsunternehmen
ja natürlich, das war ja klar
wir verkaufen dir auch jemand
der ein Jahr
innerhalb von einem Jahr
mal eine Ubuntu-VM installiert hat
als Senior Linux-Experte
Beratungsleute
die wollen Stonks machen
du benötigst eine Pause für die Elternzeit
oder ein Sabbatical
das bringt uns nicht durch Austausch
networking gefällig
nein, lass mich in Ruhe
Weiterbildung, Mitarbeiter, Beteiligungsprogramm
naja
wenn jemand auf Beratungssachen steht
dann so schlecht klingt das doch gar nicht
IT-Berater haben keine Ahnung
change my mind
ich gebe dir recht
dass die meisten keine Ahnung haben
ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass alle keine Ahnung haben
also es ist wie immer
90% Sacken, ein paar haben Ahnung
ja
ach da muss man sich anmelden
Keck
das ist Debate zum Anmelden
klingt jetzt nicht so schlecht
die Stellenanzeige
für mich ein bisschen zu hip
und zu Frontend
was hat man denn sonst jetzt
die Schweiz
ein Senior AWS
Cloud Architekt
bei IBM
ne
bei Nord Cloud von IBM
in der Schweiz
oh das gibt sicherlich Orden
das ist Big Stonks Leute
gut wenn du in der Schweiz lebst
kostet es dich auch mehr
muss man es trotzdem unterm Strich
mehr übrig haben
das ist Big Stonks
geht eigentlich
irgendwie habe ich im Kopf Schweizer Franken
mal 2 aber ist überhaupt nicht so
dann ist es doch nicht so
krass Stonks wie ich gedacht habe
ja Zufall
so was wollen sie denn
praktische AWS Erfahrung aus Erfolg
ja das Problem ist
ich suche keinen Job
ich sag es nur
da müsste ich passen
ich habe von AWS
von allen 3 Cloud Plattformen
am wenigsten Ahnung
ich kenne mich mit Azure ganz gut aus
und ich kenne mich mit Google ganz gut aus
allerdings zur Zeit geübter
weil wir hauptsächlich Google verwenden
Google Cloud
GCP
mindestens 3 Jahre
praktische Erfahrung aus erfolgreich
durchgeführten Cloud Projekten
die habe ich tatsächlich
DevOps Toolkit
und Denkweise die habe ich auch
Terraform kenne ich mich mittlerweile echt gut mit
es klingt immer blöd
wenn man sich selbst so huldigt
aber ich glaube mittlerweile kenne ich mich mit Terraform
ganz gut aus
Kenntnisse von Container Technologie
Docker EKS habe ich
EKS nicht
dafür GKE und AKS
und auch schon selbst installiert
und eingerichtet
mit Dingern die
später sind wie zum Beispiel
das man Loadbalancer verwenden kann
selbst installierten Kubernetes Cluster
und Dinge halt haben wir teilweise auch schon im Stream gemacht
aber von EKS selber keine Ahnung
ich habe gehört dass EKS von der
Konfiguration der ekligste der 3 sein muss
kann das jemand bestätigen
GKE
AKS
Config vs EKS
also ich habe das öfters gelesen dass EKS
sich am ekligsten konfigurieren lässt
weil man irgendwelche komischen Templates
konfigurieren muss und hast du nicht gesehen
Erfahrungen
in der Administration von Windows und oder
Linux Servern ja streiche Windows
gute Beherrschung von Skriptsprachen
PowerShell Bash
ich kann tatsächlich beides
also ich meine PowerShell
kriege ich zusammen Bash natürlich
deutlich besser
mindestens 5 Jahre Erfahrung
ja die habe ich mittlerweile
15 Jahre habe ich schon über 15 Jahre
sehr gute Kommunikationsfähigkeiten
englisch deutsch oder französisch
sind von Vorteil
we are all sitting in one boat
Datenbanken, SQL, NoSQL
Puppet, Chef, Ansible
kenne ich mich mit
allen 3 sogar aus
mit Chef aber am wenigsten davon
Netzwerk auch, Serverless auch
Developer Hintergrund
ja aber wir haben oft genug
gezeigt, Beratungserfahrung
nein das nicht
will ich auch nicht
The Cloud Revolution Einstellung
da hat irgendjemand
Leute ich kann euch sagen
wie sowas in eine Stellenanzeige
reinkommt, ich kann euch das genau erklären
intern
geht dieser Spruch
so
zieht sich so durch
Intranet Blog Posts
Geschäftsführung E-Mails
und sowas, weil irgendjemand sich mal
ausgedacht hat, dass The Cloud Revolution
so ein cooler Satz ist
so
und dann hat irgendjemand den Auftrag
bekommen, erstell mal eine Stellenanzeige
und der Typ wollte schleimen bei seinem
Chef
und hat deswegen The Cloud Revolution da reingeschrieben
weil er sich denkt, mein Chef
feiert das sicherlich, dass das da drin steht
so kommt
so krempelt da rein
einschlägige
Zertifizierungen sind erwünscht
zählt
zählt ein CCNA von vor 10 Jahren
oder Leute
ich habe
jetzt passt mal auf, haltet euch fest
jetzt kommt die Killer Zertifizierung
schlechthin
Keg Wade
ich habe ein Visual Basic 6
Zertifikat von
damit bin ich glaube ich
allen Bewerbern hier meilenweit voraus
außer dass ich mich
gar nicht bewerben will, aber
1996 habt ihr richtig
ne sorry, 1998
1998 war das
und wer jetzt rechnet
ja, da war ich 14
und ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, ob es Visual Basic
6 war
oder ein älteres
Visual Basic, doch es wird
Visual Basic 6 gewesen sein
da war ich 14
und wir haben in diesem Kurs
wir haben ein bisschen Visual Basic
gemacht
das Zertifikat ist gleich alt wie ich
wir haben ein bisschen
Visual Basic gemacht und dann
Leute ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wir waren alles irgendwie
13, 14, 15
jährige
und dann haben wir
vor und nach dem Kurs
Half-Life gespielt auf den Rechnern
natürlich nur mit
offiziell gekauften CDs
da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
das hat mega Bock gemacht
war richtig nice
ja, hab ich schon wieder halb vergessen
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das hier
wirklich nicht übel ist, wenn einem das zusagt
und man in der Schweiz arbeiten möchte
und ein bisschen Kohle verdienen will
wie viele sind
aus MW2 Zeiten da
du meinst hier auf Twitch
bestimmt ein paar
aber insgesamt würde ich sagen
sind auf Twitch gar nicht mal so viele
also ich weiß, dass wir viele dabei haben, die wirklich
könnt ihr mal in den Chat schreiben, dass wir viele haben
die tatsächlich schon richtig lange dabei sind
aber auf Twitch sind zunehmend
auch immer mehr Leute dabei
die den Channel echt nur von Twitch
kennen
was ich cool finde, d.h. die Twitch Empfehlungen
scheinen ja ganz gut zu funktionieren
hab ich auch nicht
Black Ops 1 hab ich extrem viel gespielt
ab und zu mal ein bisschen MW2
Friedrich Merz weiß Bescheid
der echte
so, was haben wir denn sonst noch
hier, we are hiring a few
more Superstars
das geht ja schon gut los
Rockstar Developers
werden gehiert
ähm, was davon soll ich mir denn angucken
Fullstack, bam
wir gucken jetzt Fullstack
Jazio
man weiß es nicht genau
wait a minute
we are all sitting in one boat
das ist ja in Englisch, was ist denn hier los
hallo
unsere Webseite
hat monatlich
über eine Million Aufrufe
soll ich euch
mal was top secret erzählen
hab ich doch keinem erzählt
ist aber auch nicht wirklich spektakulär
immer wenn ich
Monthly Wizards sehe
ich hatte
eine Webseite früher
zu Diablo 2 Zeiten
ach sorry
die hatte über 100.000 Aufrufe im Monat
zu Diablo 2
und
wisst ihr was
auf dieser Seite was es da gegeben hat
nein es gab keine Cheats oder sowas
es gab Trading Empfehlungen
Stonks für Diablo 2
Trading Empfehlungen
für Diablo 2
also sprich
die viel
im Trade Channel unterwegs waren
und Itemwerte wissen mussten
beziehungsweise auf welche Stats man achten soll
bei Items
hab ich so eine Seite erstellt
wo man nachgucken konnte
was für Items
aktuell quasi
ungefähr wie viel wert sind
und gefragt sind
und welche Stats davon wichtig sind
weil die so und so rollen konnten
und die war recht beliebt damals
die hatte über 100.000 Aufrufe im Monat
die Story hast du seit 2 Jahren
die hab ich noch nie erzählt
ja ich hab
doch die Story
es kann sogar sein dass ich die Story schon mal
erzählt hab
ich hab euch wahrscheinlich die Story erzählt
dass ich Diablo 2 auf Ebay Items verkauft hab
früher
das kommt aus der gleichen Zeit
und ich hab den Leuten
ich hab die Leute eigentlich damals voll gescamt
also nicht
gescamt im strafrechtlichen
Sinne und auch nicht über Ebay
sondern
ich hab
also ingame über den
Trade Channel getradet in Diablo 2
und es gab ein paar Items
die konnte man super auf Ebay verkaufen
also der 0815casualboon
der auf Ebay Items gekauft hat
der hat keine irgendwie super gut
gerollten Juwele oder so gekauft
der hat Igelhorn gekauft
zum Beispiel, Igelhorn war so ein Dauersteller
auf Ebay, das konntest du immer verkaufen
Igelhorn ging weg wie sonst was
Zoi konntest du auch verkaufen aber Igelhorn
solche Sachen konntest du super verkaufen auf Ebay
haben die ganzen Noobs gekauft
und ich hab natürlich auch
normale Items ingame getradet
über den Diablo 2 Trade Channel
und auch über
Foren und sowas
und es gab damals immer wieder Probleme
dass Items dupliziert werden konnten
und
das Problem
in Diablo 2 war, die hatten das noch
nicht so im Griff, das war so eines der ersten
richtig großen Online Games
dass duplizierte Items haben
erst später eine Unique ID pro Drop bekommen
und sobald
zweimal
das gleiche Item quasi
im gleichen Game war
wurden die Items gelöscht
also quasi zwei Items mit gleicher ID
löschen und ich hab den Leuten
damals gesagt
kostet es vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
aber ihr habt bei mir die
Garantie
wenn euer Item verschwindet in einem Game
dann bekommt ihr
bekommt ihr ein neues
und das ist glaube ich in
eineinhalb Jahren oder so
erst einmal vorgekommen, also die Chance war
echt mega gering
aber die Leute sind voll drauf angesprungen im Trade Channel
und im Forum
und die haben mir das auch geglaubt
dass ich ihnen das Item gebe
und ich hab das auch gemacht
also ich weiß noch
einer kam im Forum an
per PN und meinte hier
mein Item ist weg
und ich hatte mir für den Fall schon was vorbereitet
was ich nicht öffentlich geschrieben hab
wenn das Item weg ist, hab ich gesagt hier
du hast jetzt 5 Minuten Zeit
du musst in Game einloggen und einen Screenshot von deinem Inventar
machen mit dem Charakter wo es passiert ist
so irgendwas in der Richtung hab ich geschrieben
weil ich wollte halt sicherstellen, dass die mir kein Bullshit erzählen
so in 5 Minuten
hattest du halt keine Zeit groß zu meulen
und so, also die meisten Leute hatten da halt
hast du damit abgefangen
hat er gemacht, Item war weg
ich hab mir ein neues Item gegeben
ich glaube
ich weiß sogar noch was das war
das war eine
Immortal King Chest
mit Sockel
den Sockel hab ich alter glaube ich nicht gekriegt
aber eine neue Immortal King Chest
Chest Armor
das war kein Chest, Immortal King Armor
war das
das war das seltenste Ding glaube ich aus dem Set und auch das teuerste
ja
Big Stonks
damals in Diablo 2
ok gucken wir mal weiter
also die Webseite
von denen hat über eine Million Aufrufe im Monat
das ist ganz toll und sie haben ganz viel Potential
so also
deswegen brauchen sie
deswegen wollen sie ein Team bauen aus
erfahrenen Full Stack Engineers
um ihre aktuelle Infrastruktur
zu transformieren
und zu skalieren und zu modernisieren
diese
Super Agile Diagonal
Skalierungseffekt
ich glaube das müssen wir jetzt gar nicht weiterlesen
das ist einfach nur bla bla bla
sie überarbeiten das nicht komplett
sie wollen
irgendwie den Success alignen
für ihre Yaizo App
Long Term
kurzfristig
und pragmatische
Lösungen
sind wichtig
und
man soll einen Significant
Impact machen
auf das Core Business
alles klar
ok was ist meine Mission
was wollen sie haben
oh wir sollen die neue
neue Höhenflüge Leute
für die User Experience
sollen wir bauen
nehmen wir die Food Database
Improven
mit weiteren Features wie zum Beispiel
ähnliches Essen
vorschlagen und
Essen bewerten was ist das denn
was ist Yaizo
ich kenn die gar nicht
Healthy Weight Loss and Eating
ah das ist genau das Richtige für mich
ich mache dann
wenn ich denen eine Bewerbung schicke
ich schicke denen keine Bewerbung ich suche keinen Job
dann würde ich
einfach das PPofet bilden
ich bin genau der richtige Kandidat
wenn die fragen warum
naja guckt mal
und ein Food Calculator
was ist ein
Food Calculator
ok wir arbeiten zusammen mit dem Produkt
und dem Analyse Team
und wir iterieren mehrere Versuche durch
ok bla bla was soll man denn jetzt eigentlich
machen
Backend Team
Team Payment
Registrierungsworkflow
Symfony 5.2
ist das PHP Leute
ich glaube schon
zum salzigen Spuck
das klingt wie so ein richtig krasser
Roleplay Name
Increasing Testability
Testabdeckung
Schlüsselelemente
der Webseite
Refactoren um langfristig
Wartbarkeit zu gewährleisten
wie toll steht jetzt da eigentlich nicht drin
dass die
Seite gut aussieht
auf allen Geräten
und auf die Seiten drum herum
soll man sich auch noch kümmern
5 Jahre plus Experience
als Fullstack Engineer
und am besten dass man so
eine Transition schonmal gemacht hat
ok super ganz toller Typ
in PHP
und Javascript
und vielleicht noch
Gatsby ist das irgend so ein Static
Site Generator glaube schon
so dann soll man sich noch ganz gut auskennen
mit Responsive Design
am besten wie man das auch
für Smartphones macht
Suchmaschinenoptimierung
und dass es gescheiten und mit mehr
unterschiedlichen Browsern aussieht
Testen
Automatische Testing für Websites
also Jest oder irgendwie sowas
keine Ahnung was man da macht ihr wisst
bei mir im Stream
wir schreiben nie Tests
und Chat warum
schreiben wir keine Tests
und schreiben keine Dokumentation
und keine Kommentare
weil
weil mir keine fehlt
das ist das erste
aber darauf will ich nicht raus
guter Code dokumentiert
sich selbst
genau
und das in Kombination
wenn man frei braucht man das andere alles nicht
außerdem
korrekt wenn es keine Tests
gibt können auch keine Tests fehl schlagen
das ist ein guter Punkt
den muss ich mir merken
neulich meinte das einer im Bewerbungsgespräch
zu mir
muss ihn fragen ob er Wubblos guckt auf Twitch
und bei mir
klappt das ja wie man sieht auch
in den Programmierstreams
immer ohne Fehler
nie nie ist da bisher was kaputt
gegangen
Tests sind richtig
Friedrich Merz
wer testen muss
gesteht sich ein dass er es nicht kann
ganz einfach
ok man soll sich auskennen mit
Containerisierung und Build Pipelines
Build Pipelines
wie könnte man das gescheit auf
deutsch übersetzen ich meine
Fertigungsröhren oder
Bauröhren klingt ziemlich blöd
ich glaube das ist so ein typisches Wort was man nicht übersetzt oder
Fertigungslinien
Fertigungsstraßen
oder sowas vielleicht
was ist eine gute Übersetzung für Build Pipelines
Fertigungsstraßen
ergibt aber auch keinen Sinn
versteht keine Sau was man meint damit
ich glaube man bleibt bei
Build Pipelines
Ability to balance long term
ok
also man soll
den Spagat schaffen
zwischen
Langzeit gut funktioniert und das mal
pragmatisch was schnell auf die
Reihe kriegt
man soll excellent Problem Solving Skills
haben
Aha
Artefakt Automatisierung
Strecke
Artefakte sein die du
Pipeline
finde ich gut Artefakt Automatisierung
Strecke klingt wie nach einer schönen Microsoft Übersetzung
ok
das lesen wir jetzt nicht
also Remote
First Culture das ist schon mal gut
High Impact
steht da irgendwas was sie bezahlen
ne das ist natürlich blöd
ich finde das klingt gar nicht so schlecht
hier muss ich auch ehrlich sagen
also für PAP
Fans natürlich
nur
was hat man sonst noch schönes zu bieten
ein Senior Transformations Architekt
SAP
ok
SAP wenn es sein muss
wir sind
Adeso Orange
das ist doch auch irgendein
Personalvermittlungstyp oder
wir sind Adeso Orange
das SAP
Powerhouse
einer der Top Adressen in der
IT Welt mit beeindruckender
Wachstumsperspektive
unseren Erfolg
aber erreichen wir nur durch eins
die Menschen bei Adeso Orange
lass dich
von uns überzeugen
ok bla bla bla bla bla
Standorte
ok ich will da eh nicht hin
aber deine Rolle das erwartet
das wartet auf dich
als Senior Transformations
Architekt SAP
All Genders
das ist tatsächlich sinniger als MWD zu
schreiben da kann sich keiner beschweren
dass er sich da noch irgendwie exkludet fühlt
weil die schreiben explizit all
da kommen jetzt wieder die Leute die sagen aber ich habe gar keinen
Jetner mehr
ich fühle mich
ganz furchtbar diskriminiert
bist du das Bindeglied zwischen
Fachabteilung und umsetzender IT
deine systematische und technische Denkweise
hilft dabei uns Kunden
bla bla bla bla bla
du bist Prozess- und Systemexpertin
der die mit Leidenschaft
Daten im SAP
Irgendjemand der ernsthaft
mit Leidenschaft Daten
in SAP-Systemen analysiert
ist das wirklich ein Ding
also ist das wirklich
gibt es irgendwo einen auf der Welt der das macht
ich mein die machen das
die wollen Geld bekommen dafür
ja ok aber wirklich gerne macht das wahrscheinlich
keiner
das ist so wie wenn ich mich
morgens beispielsweise
mal auf einer Windows-Kiste einlogge
dann mache ich das
weil ich dafür bezahlt werde aber nicht
weil ich es gerne mache
mit 200k im Jahr kommt die Leidenschaft zurück
ne glaube ich nicht
ok folgende Schwerpunkte erwarten dich
bla bla bla
s
slash 4
Hanna
Transformationen
dein Aufgabenbereich
umfasst auch
carve-outs
kann mir irgendjemand erklären was das ist
das ist doch kein SAP-Wort
oder das ist irgend so ein Buzzword
cooles Business-Wort
Merger
da kann ich mir wenigstens was drunter vorstellen
aber das hat wahrscheinlich im SAP-Umfeld
eine andere
äh bedeutet
wenn zwei Unternehmen quasi
wie heißt das auf Deutsch
Zusammenschluss
wenn Firmenteile fusionieren
genau ja
wenn Firmenteile verkauft werden
Reorganisation
Data Cleansing
oder Cleansing
ich glaub Cleansing spricht man das aus
und andere
Transformations-Szenarien
Leute ich hab jetzt diesen Satz gelesen
und ich hab legit nicht
den Hauch einer Ahnung
was die überhaupt von mir wollen
du koordinierst das Migrations
Moment ich koordiniere auch noch
na gut ich bin Transformations-Architekt
dann passt das ja
Als Schnittstelle zwischen den Fachabteilungen entwickeln
oh da hätte ich ja sowas keinen Bock drauf
das ist ja eher eine Management-Position
hier
Du kennst dich mit Migrations-Werkzeugen
und Methoden wie SAP
Migration Cockpit
Now to Vion
DCS
ich dachte DCS ist dieser
dieser Flugzeug-Simulator
Digital Combat Simulator
und oder
SNP Crystal Bridge
also ganz ehrlich Leute
das SAP Umfeld ist so
voll von Business Bullshit
begriffen das ist der Wahnsinn
ja ich gette das das irgendwelche Produkte sind
aber das ist so ein typischer
wenn sich irgendwie
so ein
Super Business Enterprise Marketing
Hirn ein Produktname
ausdenkt dann kommt sowas raus
wie SNP Crystal Bridge
so ein typischer
Business Crap Name
ob es was taugt keine Ahnung
ausgezeichnete
Technische und Architektur
egal das kannst mich ja jagen
bloß weg
stimmt für SAP
sollte es direkt aus dem Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof
ausarbeiten
ist nicht so weit
wen haben wir denn in Mannheim gar nicht so weit
weg bei Bertrand
da hieß es auch Bertrand
was erwartet was suchen
die überhaupt
ein DevOps
was zum Teufel ist mit der Seite los
warum ist die so schlecht
warum suckt die Seite so
liegt es am Dark Reader
ein Auge
die Seite ist einfach so kacke
müsste man so machen dann geht es
wenn man da reinzoomt dann funktioniert es
Indeed
ok
also was erwartet sie Entwicklung Abstimmung
Konfiguration von Infrastruktur für Applikationen
ok passt
Skripten der
kontinuierlichen Integration
das habe ich selten auf
Deutsch bisher gesehen
ist doch Dark Reader
der kontinuierlichen
Integration
wo wir es gerade davon hatten was man manche Sachen
besser nicht übersetzen sollte aber das
habe ich so noch nicht gesehen
Skripten im Bereich
der kontinuierlichen Integration
und machen die auch
kontinuierliche Bereitstellung
oder kontinuierliche Auslieferung
besser oder
kontinuierliche Auslieferung machen die hoffentlich auch
elektromechanischen
Regelsystemen
sie bringen mit
ok
üblich gesagt
Embedded Software oder Software
das war es von Patrick
wobei die bestimmt keine Schweizer Gehälter
bezahlen wollen
Entwicklungserfahrung mit Node.js
oder vergleichbaren Skriptsprache
da sieht man mal wieder
dass das irgendein Personaltyp geschrieben hat
der keine Ahnung davon hat was er schreibt
dieser Satz
ergibt aus technischer Sicht
absolut keinen Sinn
Null
wisst ihr was ich habe eine gute Idee
wir haben einen Azubi bei uns
zwei Wochen jetzt
ich
merke mir den Satz jetzt mal
und morgen
schicke ich unserem Azubi den Satz
und frage ihn was ist daran falsch
oder ne was daran falsch ist
blöde Frage weil
dann weiß man ja schon
dass was falsch ist
was sagst du
zu dem Satz
Chat aber ihr wisst das doch oder
ihr wisst warum der Satz keinen Sinn macht oder
der Erste
der mir erklärt warum dieser Satz
keinen Sinn macht
mit einer Erklärung die mich überzeugt
der kriegt von mir einen Sub gegiftet
Framework ist keine Skriptsprache
ja richtig
aber ich muss sagen der Friedrich Merz
hat eigentlich
er hat eigentlich recht weil das eine Runtime ist
das ist aber ein Framework und ein Runtime
du warst der Erste
du kriegst einen Sub
Javascript ist die
Sprache
Node.js basiert auf V8
der Javascript Runtime
von Chrome
von Plink muss man ja eigentlich sagen glaube ich heute
aber die Sprache ist Javascript
in dem Fall und nicht Node.js
ok
jetzt erstmal an
Besos399 überweisen
let's go
Dankeschön für den Sub
ok was haben wir denn sonst noch
Erfahrung mit
Konfigurationsmanagement System
RIT bevorzugt
ok
richtig kontinuierliche Integration
und Bildautomatisierung
Jenkins
ich mag Jenkins
ich sag das öfters
aber
ja Jenkins ist
so ein bisschen
so ein riesen
Ding mit dem du alles machen kannst
ich persönlich mag Jenkins
Erfahrung mit agilen Software Prozessen
ja natürlich
wir sind auf GitHub in der agilen Progress Group
die wissen Bescheid
eine Rennereise
Bereitschaft ok
direkt aussortiert
sehr gute
Kommunikationskooperation und Teams
Fähigkeit sehr gute Deutsch
und Englischkenntnisse in Wort und Schrift
Sie identifizieren sich mit dieser Position
oder
sind gespannt auf ihre neue Herausforderung
sind wir gespannt auf sie
das ist ein richtig schöner 0815 Satz
selbstverständlich wäre ich
ja wenn nicht ist die Anzeige raus
ja
von Homeoffice steht nichts drin
steht flexible Arbeitszeiten
ja ich mein
ist jetzt nichts wo ich sagen würde
ok da müsste man sich unbedingt bewerben
aber klingt jetzt auch nicht so
so mies ja
klingt sehr 0815
Chat wir haben es geschafft
pünktlich
zur FastBadGetTime
ja es gibt Riesenunterschiede
zwischen GitHub Actions und Jenkins
GitHub Actions kannst du richtig schön über YAML konfigurieren
wobei bei Jenkins
ich habe lange kein Jenkins mehr neu aufgebaut
bei Jenkins gibt es doch
mittlerweile auch sowas oder
habe ich nicht mal irgendwas von Jenkins
in irgendeinem Blogpost letztens gelesen
ich glaube sowas gibt es doch für Jenkins
mittlerweile auch das man das so YAML mäßig
konfigurieren kann
ich kenn Jenkins nur noch aus der Zeit
da hat man im Webinterface
einen Job angelegt und hat dann
im Webinterface irgendwelche Bash-Scripts reinkopiert
im Vorfeld vielleicht noch
dieses Git-Repo
ist ja auch wichtig
magst du eins trinken? Ja habe ich gerade schon
Jenkins-File in Groovy
ich habe mal was
ein bisschen umfangreicheres gemacht für
Confluence in Groovy
bei dem letzten Laden
wo ich gearbeitet habe
da habe ich eine Seite gehabt die automatisch
refresht wird
sie wurde automatisch gerendert
und das war
Confluence
ist ja in Java und
Backend-Technisch war das in Groovy
Groovy war ganz okay
aber mittlerweile muss ich sagen
ich würde jetzt auch nicht mehr freiwillig
was drin machen
ich würde meine Pipelines am liebsten in COBOL
programmieren wenn ich ehrlich bin
dann hat man wenigstens Zeilennummern dranstehen
falls der Editor das nicht kann
ich habe übrigens auch
ein zweites Paar Laufschuhe gekauft
Ritter Ross, Dankeschön für den Sub
wo wir gerade dabei sind
letzte Viertelstunde muss ich euch noch was zeigen
ich war vor ein paar Tagen
mega im Arsch
und zwar
schaut mal hier
ich jetzt
neue Bestzeit 5km
5 Minuten 55
im Durchschnitt pro Kilometer
und die Strecke ist gar nicht einfach
es geht zweimal die Brücke
hoch und zum Schluss hin auch noch leicht bergauf
also ganz flach oder
auf einer Bahn wäre ich wahrscheinlich bei
keine Ahnung vielleicht sogar
unter 55 gewesen
ich war aber echt im Arsch
danach, meine normale
Strecke geht 6km
und ich bin nach 5km
habe ich gesagt es reicht
und bin zurückgelaufen
es hat mir wirklich
es hat mir komplett gereicht
ich habe
echt geschnauft
die letzten Kilometer
zwischendurch schon
also wisst ihr
für mich ist es
in der Geschwindigkeit zu rennen
das musst du ja mehr oder weniger von Anfang an
rennen die ganze Zeit
dass du es hin haust
ähm
du läufst den ersten Kilometer und denkst dir
das hältst du doch im Leben
keine 5km durch
dann ist der zweite Kilometer rum
das hältst du doch im Leben
keine 5km durch
das denkst du dir eigentlich bis der letzte Kilometer
anfängt
bis der letzte Kilometer anfängt und du denkst dir
okay jetzt hast du es gleich geschafft
also Leute
da war ich echt im Arsch
aber das war ja so erstmal mein Ziel
5km unter 6 Minuten
ich mach das ja auch
erst seit einem Monat
bisschen über einem Monat
also mein Ziel ist eigentlich
10km unter 6 Minuten
dann bin ich erstmal zufrieden
ich mein 6km
pack ich demnächst bestimmt
wenn ich es jetzt mit 5 geschafft hab
aber ich mach das ja auch
ich versuch ja auch nicht
jedesmal mich zu übertreffen
das kannst du ja nicht machen
da hast du ja keinen Bock mehr
und bringt ja auch nichts
so alle
also einmal in der Woche oder so
renn ich mal mit komplett Volldampf
weiter schneller gehen
ich mein ich hätte es theoretisch
noch ein paar hundert Meter geschafft
und vielleicht auch ein bisschen schneller
so wenn ich danach komplett dead gewesen wäre
aber ich muss ja noch heimkommen
ja
also das probier ich
10km und dort unter 6 Minuten
pro Kilometer so im Durchschnitt
also das längste was ich
bisher mal gelaufen hab
ist 7,8km
das ging eigentlich erstaunlich gut
gibt es noch Grafen?
ja es gibt Grafen aber die hab ich nirgends wo hochgeladen
Crafts gibt es auch
in der App
hab ich aber
nicht hochgeladen
Charts gibt es da oben
Leute
soll ich euch mal einen richtigen Pains Champ Witz erzählen
Calories not found
ok
also hier oben gibt es
Grafen
mal gucken
also ich denke
also wie gesagt 7,8km
war bisher das längste was ich gerannt bin
also mit Aufzeichen von der Uhr hier
das war aber eine ganze Ecke
langsamer
die bin ich
auf 8km
bin ich gelaufen mit 7 Minuten 40
da bin ich aber auch wirklich absichtlich
entspannt
gerannt
weil
ich weiß ja nicht wie gut ich das durchhalte
ich werde das demnächst
bestimmt mal wieder probieren mit 7
oder sagen wir mal 8km
und dann
ein bisschen zügiger
weil jetzt weiß ich ja ungefähr was ich so durchhalte
ja
also wie gesagt mein Ziel ist
10km packen unter 6 Minuten
pro Kilometer
dann bin ich erstmal happy
natürlich ist das noch nicht super krass schnell
aber das muss ich ja auch nicht
unbedingt sein
BMI?
weiß ich nicht, kannst du dir ausrechnen wenn du willst
haben wir letztens gemacht
ich wiege
zwischen 91 und 94
so je nachdem wann man sich drauf stellt
sag mal in der App habe ich 93
93 Kilo drinnen stehen
das ist auch meistens so in dem Dreh
irgendwas meistens 92,8 oder so
und ich bin
1,74 groß
also ich bin schon noch ein bisschen
nicht immer so schlimm
aber noch ein bisschen
nicht immer so schlimm wie vor ein paar Jahren
vor ein paar Jahren war ich 108,5
da war ich richtig pepo fett
also vor ein paar Jahren ist gut
vor 2 Jahren oder so
naja ob ich einen Marathon
laufen will
ein Marathon bedeutet ja
mit der Geschwindigkeit
also sag mal 6 Minuten pro Kilometer
Minuten
2,2 Stunden
aber sag mal so
bis ich das
länger durchhalte
also bis ich das
ich war wirklich im Arsch danach
also ich schaff das
vielleicht 6 Kilometer
dann ist aber auch Schluss erstmal
also wie gesagt mein Ziel ist erstmal
dass ich das über 10 Kilometer schaffe
du schreibst ja schon dann vielleicht mal
also mal gucken
aktuell geht es wirklich gut
ich hab sogar letztens
das erste mal das probiert
was im Internet immer empfohlen wird
dass man nicht immer nur
jedes mal die gleiche Strecke
durchgehend rennt
sondern bin ich hier in so einen kleinen Park gegangen
da ist eine Runde im Park genau 500 Meter
und dann bin ich
4 mal 500 Meter gerannt
also 2 Kilometer
4 mal 500 Meter mit Pause
dazwischen
mit ungefähr
5,15
da war ich aber
nach 500 Meter schon echt im Arsch
und
dann hab ich glaube ich
1,5 Minuten Pause gemacht
das ist ja das was
empfohlen wird damit man sich dran gewöhnt
so grundsätzlich schneller zu rennen
ja
Microsprints quasi
ich weiß noch nicht mal
was der Satz mir sagen soll
ich hab übrigens noch ein zweites Paar Schuhe gekauft
welche die ein bisschen
stabiler sind weil
meine super gepolsterten sind mir
doch manchmal ein bisschen zu wobbly
ich hab mir noch gekauft
ein GTS
irgendwie sowas hier
ich glaub das hier
so komische Farb her
die sind ein bisschen stabiler
und ein bisschen fester
als meine
gepolsterten Schuhe
ich seh schon komm
wenn ich wirklich das dauerhaft
weitermach
dann hab ich irgendwann
brauch ich einen eigenen Schrank für Laufschuhe
also wie gesagt ich versteh noch nicht mal was der Satz
mir sagen soll also
Adaption des Körpers an Grundlagen
Ausdauer ist echt extrem wirst du merken
heißt
ich
merke nix ich weiß nicht
erklär mal den Satz ich würd's gerne verstehen
aber ich versteh's nicht
128 Puls du lebst am Limit
128 Puls
doch vollkommen in Ordnung
also ich hatte
ein Puls
ganz ehrlich wenn du gesund bist
sage ich als jemand der
medizinisch keine Ahnung hat aber
wenn du wirklich gesund bist
ist es egal dann stirbst du nicht
einfach so weil du zu hohen Puls hast
also ich hatte
zwischenzeitlich 186
lass mich mal reingucken
als es die Brücke hochging
ähm die zweite Runde
die zweite Runde
die zweite Runde Brücke hoch
ähm da hatte ich glaube ich
186 oder sowas mal
kurzzeitig
da hab ich's aber auch richtig gemerkt
dass das jetzt ist kurz vorm Umkippen
ähm
lass mich mal kurz in die Stats
gucken
was das war
ja das war
am Sonntag
oder
ne
stand da das Datum dabei
13.
so
Hanau Running
Charts
ja Maximumpuls
das hab ich auch gemerkt
also das
da hab ich wirklich geschnauft
was für Material
ist das Armband deiner Uhr
ein komisches Plastik
ist es schwer mal eben 5km zu rennen
ganz ohne Training
ja
also ich mach das ja noch nicht lang
aber das allererste Mal
also bei mir war das so
das allererste Mal als ich das probiert hab
hab ich nur irgendwie 3x 1km oder so
geschafft
insgesamt glaube ich irgendwie
3,7 oder so Kilometer
mit ein bisschen Pause dazwischen gelaufen
und da hab ich
da war ich erstaunt
da hab ich mir gedacht ey
also das war wirklich nicht schnell
das war irgendwie 8, 8,5 Minuten pro Kilometer
und
und auch mit Pause dazwischen
aber da hab ich mir gedacht es geht doch eigentlich ganz gut
und daraufhin hab ich dann angefangen
tatsächlich jeden zweiten Tag
jeden zweiten Tag zu rennen
und nach kurzer Zeit
hab ich die 5km geschafft
ohne größere Probleme
so nach 3-4 mal
3-4 mal üben
nicht schnell
ja nicht schnell
erst unter 8
dann unter 7 und jetzt unter 6
natürlich geht das nicht immer so krass weiter
das wird immer flacher so logarithmisch
quasi
aber so ganz aus dem Stehgreif
hab ich die 5km
vielleicht geschafft
aber doch sehr im Arsch
so ganz ohne Übung ist 5km
durchgehend laufen echt nicht ohne
ja wenn es danach geht
dürfte ich maximal 180 haben
mein Mikrofon knackt wieder, nice
gut dass ich gleich ins Bett muss
ja aber wie gesagt
also ich
müsste mal unbedingt so einen Test machen
am besten auf irgendeinem Platz mit einer ordentlichen Laufbahn
also
ich hab schon bei normalem
Lauftraining jetzt
maximal 186 mal gehabt
das war aber nur kurz
und als die Brücke hochging
aber ich hätte durch
ich meine ich musste noch 2,5km zurücklaufen
also
ich hätte durchaus noch ein bisschen mehr
Gas geben können
also ohne es zu wissen
ich würde mal sagen
mein maximaler Puls ist wahrscheinlich
192, 193 oder irgendwie sowas
also da sieht man daran
so richtig rechnen kann man das nicht, ich bin fast 40
da dürfte ich ja maximal 180 haben
es ist halt
sehr individuell pro
Mensch letztendlich
hoher Puls im Ruhezustand ist nicht gut
das hab ich gemerkt als ich
Corona hatte
da hab ich mit Corona im Bett gelegen
und hatte einen Puls von 105
oder 110 teilweise
das lag an Corona
also das wusste ich erst gar nicht
ich hab im Bett gelegen und
hab nur gedacht alter du bist
übelst im Arsch, du bist übelst krank
du bist übelst kaputt
warum kannst du denn nicht pennen
und ich hab im Bett gelegen
und ich konnte nicht schlafen
und ich hab mich übelst
unruhig gefühlt auch
und während ich Corona hatte bin ich teilweise
die halbe Nacht
hier ums Bett
und im oberen Stockwerk rumgelaufen
ich bin so viel rumgelaufen
langsam
bis mir die Waden wehgetan haben
zumal ich auch viel zu wenig gegessen hab
weil es nichts geschmeckt hat
und wenig Nährstoffe drin
die Waden wehgetan bei Corona deswegen
und irgendwann bin ich dann mal auf die
glorreiche Idee gekommen
mir mein Puls, äh nicht Puls
mein Blutdruckmessgerät mal
anzulegen und das hat dann gesagt
Max du hast im Sitzen
im Bett einfach einen Puls von fast 110
hab ich gesagt oh
ja daran könnte es liegen
dass ich nicht richtig pennen kann
aber jetzt ist wieder alles gut
jetzt ist wieder alles gut
das war wirklich nur wegen Corona
da hab ich mir auch ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht
lass mal kurz gucken
was hab ich denn jetzt
ich halt mir mal kurz die Uhr
ans Handgelenk
die ist da eigentlich relativ schnell
jetzt hab ich grad 72
jetzt ist es ziemlich konstant auf 68
also sprich in dem Zustand
könnte ich jetzt pennen gehen
und ich hatte einfach
über 40 Schläge die Minute
während Corona mehr einfach nur beim im Bett liegen
also das
war echt unangenehm
ich brauch das nicht nochmal
wie sieht es mit dem Muskelaufbau aus
merkst du schon am Körper dass du kräftiger
geworden bist
ich weiß nicht
ich weiß auch nicht ob man vom Laufen wirklich so viel
kräftiger wird
also den Eindruck
den ich habe ist
erstens
meine generelle Haltung
im Laufen ist besser
also auch wenn ich einfach nur spazieren gehe
häng ich nicht mehr so
in den Seilen
und ich bin allgemein
bewegungsfreudiger
nennen wir es mal so
also
wenn ich denke ey
brauchst du mal einen Tee
geh ich auch ohne mir zu denken
oh nee kein Bock
flitz ich schnell runter in die Küche
ich bin allgemein ein bisschen
bewegungsfreudiger geworden dadurch
was ich aktuell
nicht machen kann ist
echt alter
das war doch den ganzen Stream heute nicht oder
das ist doch jetzt erst
das war doch den ganzen Tag heute nicht
auch
mein Gott was ein Scheiß alter
ok ich muss mir
wir machen das demnächst mal anders
ich schreib mir das mal auf
ich kauf mir ein neues Audio Interface
oder Chat
wisst ihr was wir machen
ich stöpsel mal kurz hier ab
so ich bin wieder da
und jetzt hab ich das Mikrofon
mal
direkt angestöpselt ans Audio Interface
ohne meine dumme
Verlängerung dazwischen
ist das jetzt besser
ernsthaft
liegt das wirklich an diesem
liegt das wirklich an diesem dummen
Verlängerungskabel
Keck Weight Verlängerungskabel
da war es wieder ok
war
naja
nur gut
ja Max sag Bescheid wenn es wieder
komische Geräusche macht
langsam laufen ist ja auch relativ
langsam ist ja
für jeden so ein bisschen unterschiedlich
also was ich nicht mag ist
so dieses
ultra langsame rumkrebsen
ich weiß dass man das eigentlich
machen soll
aber ich komm mir so langsam vor
also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie mit
keine Ahnung
7,5 oder 8 Minuten pro Kilometer
rumkrebse da hab ich das Gefühl
ich lauf rückwärts
also ich muss jetzt schauen wie sie ordentlich
Zug drin haben also normalerweise
hab ich
so ungefähr 100
bis 154
Puls
beim Rennen
wenn ich langsam laufe hab ich so 148
147 oder sowas
und wenn ich mir halt richtig reinhau
dann hab ich sowas halt im Durchschnitt
und Maximalpuls weiß ich halt nicht genau
ich vermute mal irgendwas um 193
oder sowas also 186
hatte ich schon beim normalen Brücke
hochrennen
achso dass man Ausdauer echt gut trainieren
kann dass man schnell Fortschritte sieht
ja es wird aber trotzdem denke ich mal
es wird wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen
logisch sein von der Kurve her
dass man
erstmal sich ganz gut verbessert aber
man sich danach wahrscheinlich auch
tatsächlich
gut verbessert aber
dass sich immer weniger
rein in der Zeit
niederschlägt weil es ist halt ein krasser
Unterschied von
keine Ahnung von
von 3 Minuten
äh sag mal von 4 Minuten auf 3 Minuten
oder von 3 Minuten auf
2,30 ja also von 4 Minuten
kriegen viele mit Training
hin 3 Minuten ist ja schon
fast fast
je nachdem welche Distanz
Elite und
2,30 ist halt
Weltrekord so also
das macht
das macht es halt für jede Sekunde
Verbesserung brauchst du dann halt schon
ein bisschen mehr und
ich weiß das jetzt erst zu schätzen
der Marathon Weltrekord Leute
der liegt bei
also der nicht ganz offizieller
aber der ist aber ungefähr bei 2 Stunden
knapp unter 2 Stunden aber der offizielle ein bisschen
über 2 Stunden aber um 2 Stunden
so
man muss sich das mal vorstellen 2 Stunden
für um die 40 Kilometer
das heißt
die Rennen
dort mit etwas über 20 kmh
das sind ungefähr
glaub 2 Minuten 50
2 Minuten 50 müssen wir jetzt
vergleich mal ungefähr 2 Minuten
50 pro Kilometer über
40 Kilometer
ich bin nach 5
Kilometer mit 5 Minuten
55 im Arsch
und die rennen doppelt
so schnell
fast doppelt so schnell
über 40 Kilometer
so und um das
ich hab das letztes mal ausgerechnet
um zu sehen wie
hat es geknackst gerade
wann hat es geknackst hier
über 40 Kilometer
so und
um das
über 40 Kilometer
hier hat nichts geknackst
und die rennen doppelt so schnell
hier war es wieder ja
hm
vielleicht doch irgendein Problem
oder
das könnte auch an Windows liegen
man weiß bei Windows nie
bei Windows ist man
nie geweiht vor sowas
zumindest ich hab das letztes mal
ausgerechnet wenn man mal
den 100 Meter Weltrekord nimmt
also ungefähr 9 Sekunden
das bedeutet
wenn jemand
mit
der gleichen Geschwindigkeit
wie beim 100 Meter Weltrekord
den Kilometer laufen würde
was nicht so richtig funktioniert
aber nur mal angenommen
dann bräuchte er eineinhalb Minuten
für einen Kilometer
und wenn man das mal vergleicht
mit
den 100 Meter Weltrekord
der bräuchte für den Kilometer
eineinhalb Minuten
und die rennen
über 40 Kilometer
2,50 bis 3 Minuten
das heißt die laufen
über 40 Kilometer
quasi
also
der Typ läuft nur
kurzzeitig mal doppelt so schnell
über 100 Meter
das ist ultra krass
also das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen
wie heftig krass das ist
kein Wunder dass das nur eine Handvoll Leute schaffen
aber das ist übertrieben brutal
kann ich mir vorstellen
bist du in Frankfurt mitgelaufen
beim JP Morgan Challenge Lauf
das ist ungefähr so lang
pass mal auf, mach ich nächstes Jahr mit, easy
aber 38 Minuten
ist gar nicht schlecht
das ist durchaus okay
38 Minuten für 5 Kilometer
wenn man gar nicht geübt ist
guck mal
so viel besser ist es bei mir auch nicht
ich hab 29
37 für 5 Kilometer
ich war übelst im Arsch
und ich bin auch nicht lang geübt
also ich mach das erst ein bisschen über einen Monat
38 Minuten ist gar nicht schlecht
die GoPro Halterung
wie heißt diese
Social Laufen App
wo die ganzen krassen Influencers
am Start sind
Strava? Strada?
ich werde jetzt
Fitness Influencer
also irgendwann
werde ich mal angenommen
also eine Sache werde ich machen
das probiere ich echt
mal angenommen ich fühle mich wirklich so
wenn ich 5 Kilometer schaffe unter
60 Minuten
dann nehme ich euch mal mit
mit einer GoPro oder sowas
allerdings ohne mich zu leaken dabei
den habe ich auch manchmal
hast du Fahrradfahren versucht?
besser für die Gelenke
nee, hab ich nicht
hab ich mir aber tatsächlich überlegt
ob ich mir das nicht mal angucken soll
ich hab zur Zeit meinen Spaß daran gefunden
mich tatsächlich etwas mehr zu bewegen
hätte mir das mal einer vor 15 Jahren erzählt
oder sowas, hätte ich gesagt
piss dich alle, geh weg, erzähl mir nichts
von mehr bewegen
Max, was erzählst du hier
für einen Blödsinner?
also das halte ich mal für ein Gerücht
dass man beim Bewegen
durch Bewegung Muskeln verliert
also der Zusammenhang erschließt sich mir nicht
ich mach das nicht nach der Arbeit
ich mach das vor der Arbeit
oder besser gesagt
ich starte Homeoffice, gucke ein bisschen rum
mach meine Session auf
futter was dabei
und dann geh ich schnell
ne Runde rennen
ich mach das morgens, abends hab ich da auch keinen Bock drauf
außerdem kann ich
geht das morgens einfacher
und man ist gefühlt geistig ein bisschen fitter
den restlichen Tag rüber
also man, hab ich zumindest den Eindruck
dass mein Hirn ein bisschen besser funktioniert
dafür ist man den Tag über
körperlich ein bisschen kaputt
das hab ich auch gehört
wenn man Beine trainiert ist der Bizeps weg
das hab ich auch schon gehört
aber wenn man den Bizeps wieder haben will
muss man die Bostransformation machen
ich kenn das
das ist so ein alternatives Startmenü
ich will aber keine Third-Party-Sachen benutzen müssen
für sowas
das sagen viele
also ich habs wieder gemerkt
auch bei der Sache mit
ich geh mal ne Runde rennen
ich hab von heute auf morgen angefangen damit
hab festgestellt, taugt was und mach jetzt weiter
hätte ich mir das erst ewig lange
überlegt, hätte ich es
wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht
ich hab mir gedacht, weißt was Max, probier doch mal aus
wie weit du kommst, dann hat das besser funktioniert
als gedacht und seitdem mach ich das jeden zweiten Tag
fertig
da gab es so, just do it
man glaubt gar nicht
wie gut man in Sachen werden kann
in kürzerer Zeit als man denkt
wenn man es einfach mal ausprobiert
die Chance, dass man keinen Bock
drauf hat, gibt es immer, aber dann hat man es wenigstens mal ausprobiert
morgen renn ich zum ersten Mal
mit den neuen Schuhen
mal gucken wie die so sind
weil meine gedämpften
gehen mir auch ein bisschen auf den Keks
das ist auch nichts für jeden Tag
ok Leute
noch ein bisschen Random Talk
gehalten jetzt hier 20 Minuten
wir sehen uns
ich hau jetzt ab
bis denn
Bettgetime, boomer müde, boomer schlafen
bis denn, machts gut
CU
Q
oh hier
richtig
Fitnessstudio Pics
ich wollte das eigentlich gar nicht anklicken gerade
Bettgetime
machts gut, CU